[оплески]
[музика]
Доброго дня всім
Вітаю всіх учасників наших глядачів на
традиційній освітній серпневій
конференції а саме на за тематикою
цифрова трансформація освіти в умовах
війни Сьогодні у нас буде дуже багато
цікавих спікерів і різних тем але
насправді перш за все Я хотів би
вшанувати пам'ять загиблих на цій війні
хвилиною мовчання
Дякую вам дякую всім
заради кого ми працюємо і завдяки кому
ми можемо організовувати цю конференцію
сьогодні
перш за все Я хочу подякувати всім
освітянам всім вчителям директорам
закладів освіти всім тим хто працює
для того щоб майбутнє покоління в нашій
країні було освіченим мало ті безмежні
можливості які нам дарує цей час
також я хочу подякувати всім нашим
міжнародним партнерам завдяки яким
всі наші ініціативи відбуваються цього
року які нас підтримують які будуть
продовжувати нас підтримувати деякі з
них будуть сьогодні виступати деякі з
них сьогодні долучитись до нашої
конференції не змогли але Ми дуже-дуже
дякуємо всім міжнародним організаціям
всім нашим партнерам всім країнам які
нам допомагають
сьогодні на нас чекає 4 блоки
презентації доповідей різних спікерів
саме з цих блоків і складається на нашу
думку цифрова трансформація в закладі
освіти першим блоком буде
цифрова інфраструктура
далі за нашою програмою
на нас чекають доповіді з тематики
цифрового контенту і тих електронних
освітніх ресурсів які можна
використовувати для дистанційного і
змішаного навчання після цього ми
поговоримо про цифрову компетентність
викладачів а також можливості для
підвищення кваліфікації і як останньою
темою сьогодні буде централізація
процесів оскільки перехід до
дистанційного навчання це насправді
перехід до дистанційної роботи закладу
освіти коли і процеси в закладі спрощені
і переведені в цифровий вигляд
тож щоб не займати багато часу Я хочу
сказати що мудрувати сьогоднішню нашу
зустріч нам допоможе Антоніна букач
директорка академії цифрового розвитку
Антоніна запрошує вас
Дякую Дмитре І я б хотіла зосередити
всіх глядачів на організаційних питаннях
та можливості взаємодіяти із спікерами
під час прямого ефіру для цього мені
допоможе трансляція екрану яку Я наразі
умикаю і перше базовий ресурс якими
використовуємо це сайт заходу саме на
ньому ви бачите вбудовану трансляцію яка
є відео на YouTube і Ми запрошуємо вас
буде активними трансляція на сьогодні
відбувається канал YouTube Міністерство
освіти і науки канал YouTube історії і
група освіторії для того щоб ставити
питання наживо в чаті будь ласка
відкрийте таку сторінку нові вкладці і
скористайтеся можливістю в першому блоці
ви зможете такі запитання ставити
наступна можливість до якої ми вас
Запрошуємо це
використати зворотний зв'язок в разі
коли ви не знайшли або не має посилання
на наш сайт давайте ще раз ознайомимося
із посиланням перше безпосередньо в
прямому ефірі я виводжу для вас qr-код
який ви можете поставити на паузу і
відсканувати для того щоб відкрити
сторінку такого сайту друга можливість -
це ще раз наголошую відкрийте трансляцію
в окремій сторінці і під відео на всіх
ресурсах ви знайдете покликання на сайт
в інтерактивному вигляді використовуйте
і долучайтеся до взаємодії разом із нами
якщо ми говоримо про взаємодію то на
лівій бічній навігаційні панелі До речі
такий сайт відкриється легко на
будь-якому пристрої чи комп'ютер великий
мобільний скористайтесь переходом до
розділу з відповідною назвою взаємодії і
будь ласка це анонімна форма опитування
ви якими запрошуємо вас долучитися до
взаємодії і разом з нами дати відповідь
на три актуальні питання а підсумки ми
будемо підбивати в ході роботи із кожним
блоком для того щоб бачити вашу
інформацію і орієнтуватися у тому як ви
з нами взаємодіяти найважливіше питання
- це програма нашого заходу Ви побачили
в навігаційній структурі що є
відповідний розділ якщо ви до нього
перейдете То можете разом із нашими
спікерами орієнтуватися щодо
запланованих виступів і відповідно
перший блок який має назву цифрова
інфраструктура якраз і розпочне пан
Дмитро прошу
[музика]
Дякую Антоніна
тож розпочнемо перший блок а саме
цифрової інфраструктури з такою вже
відомої теми ноутбук кожному вчителю
насправді програма ноутбук кожному
вчителю І взагалі цей слоган це наша
мета це така без альтернативна мета в
сфері освіти яку підтримують і Міністр
освіти і міністра цифрової трансформації
вся наша команда уряд і взагалі ми
вважаємо що це є однозначно надзвичайно
важливою метою для того щоб рухатися не
тільки в
ефективне дистанційне або змішане
навчання А просто для того щоб у кожного
вчителя було своє цифрове персональне
робоче місце і можна було працювати
комфортно як усі ми працюємо зараз з
цією конференцією тож почати Я хочу з
слайду який я презентував рівно рік тому
на Серпневий конференції так само в
місті Миколаїв дуже була гарна
конференція і тоді ми казали про те що в
системі освіти зараз є більше 400 тисяч
комп'ютерів на жаль з яких майже 50%
старша 5 років загальна потреба в
комп'ютері в комп'ютерах на той час
згідно розрахунків які ви бачите на
екрані складала 105 тисяч комп'ютерів
але навіть якщо уявити що всі ці 15 000
комп'ютерів були б закуплені то ви
бачите в порівнянні з іншими країнами це
навіть не дало б Нам тієї кількості
комп'ютерів в розрахунку на одного учня
в школі які мають інші країни Але
минулого року за цією програмою за
субвенцією з державного бюджету було
закуплено більш ніж 62 тисячі
комп'ютерів всю інформацію про всі
закупівлі в кожній області ви можете це
побачити за посиланням на сайті
Міністерства цифрової трансформації є
інтерактивне дажборт з мапою з усіма
посиланнями на всі закупівлі які
відбувалися протягом минулого року в
результаті було закуповано
6200074 ноутбуки для вчителів в усіх
областях України цього року на жаль ми
не могли відштовхуватися від тих даних
які збирали Минулого року статистичній
звітності оскільки на жаль є окуповані
території є територією які були
окуповані потім відвойовані але на жаль
заклади пошкоджені зруйновані
розграбовані присутні по всій країні
тому спільно з організацією юнісеф і
освітнім кластером ми провели
загальнодержавне опитування в якому
брали участь громади які вказували нам
серед інших запитань свої потреби в
ноутбуках для
треба вчителів в гаджетах для учнів та в
інших девайсах і інших потребах які вони
мають Ви також можете ознайомитися з
підсумковим звітом він доступний
публічно для всіх в результаті цього
опитування
області верифікували і вказали що
потрібно більш ніж 165 тисяч комп'ютерів
саме для вчителів для організації
дистанційного та змішаного навчання
тобто потреба зросла
і вже станом на сьогодні станом на зараз
5000 ноутбуків були закуплені
організацією юнісеф і доставлені до 10
областей які найбільше постраждали від
повномасштабного агресії Російської
Федерації і ми маємо домовленість з
компанією Google з якою ми вже підписали
меморандум про надання нам у подарунок
43 тисяч ноутбуків хромбуків від
компанії Google Частина цих ноутбуків
зараз вже знаходиться на фабриці і на
них наносяться Українська розкладка
клавіатури і вони будуть доставлені за
допомогою з допомогою
організації Юнеско до наших областей і
далі передані використання вчителям так
само ми ведемо переговори і знаємо що
багато інших організацій та компаній
також закуповують або готові подарувати
ноутбуки свого виробництва тому
сподіваємося що цього року ми свою мету
виконаємо і кожного вчителя буде
персональний гаджет для роботи як
дистанційному так і в змішаному так і в
очному форматі і так само для підвищення
своєї кваліфікації
Дякую І тепер переходимо до наступного
спікера нашого запрошеного Гостя з
міністерства цифрової трансформації який
розкаже нам про підключення укриттів
шкільних укриттів до Інтернету та до
wi-fi оскільки частина інфраструктури є
саме підключення до Інтернету і так само
в усіх наших опитуваннях всі зазначають
що це є один з найважливіших аспектів
організації навчального процесу всього
Денні Андрій вітаю Доброго дня
Добрий день
Дякую власне за запрошення Дмитре по
цифровій інфраструктури в цілому Я хотів
би розпочати з загальною ситуацією у нас
в минулому році реалізувався такий
важливий проект інтернет-субвенція тут
мова саме йде про підключення до
швидкісного інтернету зокрема і
навчальних закладів
протягом минулого року і частково
Протягом цього року було підключено
тільки більше ніж тисячу закладів
загальної середньої шкіри освіти більше
ніж півториш тисячі дошкільних
навчальних закладів і наразі проект ще
продовжується за рахунок минулорічного
фінансування тобто за тиждень там
одна-дві школи дитячі садочки
підключаються до швидкісного інтернету
[музика]
з приводу проекту wi-fi викриття власне
Ми е-е з разом з міністерством освіти
започат- започаткували таку ініціативу
оскільки в деяких школах якщо не
помиляюсь це більше третина шкіл
починається навчальний процес з нового
навчального року відповідно враховуючи
періодичність повітряних тривог діти
змушені будуть доволі
часто спускатися до укриття або
бомбосховища і відповідно
ініціатива wi-fi викриттях полягає в
тому щоб діти там вчителі як які будуть
перебувають під час повітряної тривоги в
укриття щоб вони залишалися на зв'язку і
за можливості навіть продовжували
навчальний процес з використанням
власної інформаційно-обчислювальної
техніки Я зараз спробую заширити екран
[музика]
Так зараз секунду
сподіваюся що видно мій екран це власне
дашборд який був розроблений нашою
командою тут ми в реальному часі
дивимося скільки які школи подаються з
яких регіонів і як відбувається прогрес
самого проекту тобто наразі в нас
загальна кількість шкіл які надали
інформацію Це близько 5 тисяч по всій
Україні
904 школи з них або вже обладнані wi-fi
в укриттям або перебувають в процесі
обладнання і власне майже 4000 шкіл ще
потребують потребують такого обладнання
ми Звернулися до соціального
відповідального бізнесу це
інтернет-провайдери це виробники тебе
комунікаційного обладнання
та вони вже розпочали процес Вчора ми
вже передали
50060 роутерів до
40 інтернет-провайдерів які власне
почали вже всі необхідні роботи для
влаштування wi-fi
в нас ще планується на передачу роутерів
тобто на жаль скоріш за все Не встигнуть
все зробити до 1 вересня бо є проблеми з
логістикою обладнання з країн Євросоюзу
але ми все одно будемо прискорювати
компанії завершить всі необхідні роботи
протягом вересня місяця
для того щоб податися для участі проекту
треба від управління освіти відправити
заявку Від міністерства освіти декілька
тижнів тому був лист з посиланням на
електронну форму за допомогою якої можна
відповідно Заповнити цю заявку
власне для якщо вже підключена школа ми
просимо звітуватись про підключення
відповідно є посилання в провайдерів і
провайдери проводять всі необхідні
тестування швидкості
та підтверджують факти підключення
самого укриття
у нас Ми проекту ходить ділимо на два
етапи в перший етап попадають заклади
загальної середньої освіти як найбільш
пріоритетні установи відповідно їх
підключають під першу пріоритет надалі
ми будемо аналізувати динаміку
підключення ми будемо дивитися які
обладнання наявне яке обладнання вже
приїхало з
Євросоюзу до України і підключати до
цього проекту вже інші освітні заклади
це
професійно-технічне училище це дитячий
садочки університети тобто теж
використовуємо так організувати процес
щоб протягом вересня не тільки заклади
загальної середньої освіти були
підключені але які всі інші навчальні
заклади в принципі все якщо в когось
виникають питання з приводу цього
проекту можна звертатися або до Дмитра
або до мене
власне допоможемо відповімо на всі
питання Дякую за увагу
Дякую Андрій і Дякую за те що ви робите
Дякую Міністерство цифрової
трансформації і тобі особисто за цю
чудову можливість закладам освіти
підключатись до інтернету обладнувати
свої заклади свої укриття це чудова і
важлива робота і дуже класно що вона не
зупиняється під час війни тому що вона
лише набирає актуальності і сподіваюся
що протягом наступного року вдасться ще
більше
Дякую тобі і ми будемо вам за дякую вам
за продуктивну співпрацю
дякую будемо переходити тоді до
наступного нашого запитання до наступної
теми І як ви могли вже здогадатися ця
тема стосується забезпечення учнів
девайсами це дуже важлива тема оскільки
лише з нашого опитування спільно з
юнісеф ми бачимо більш ніж 200 тисяч
девайсів вказаних як потреба саме для
учнів для дистанційного навчання на жаль
держава не може забезпечити всіх учнів
персональними гаджетами Як деякі країни
роблять починаючи з якогось класу У нас
немає бюджету і найближчим часом скоріш
за все не буде бюджету на такі масштабні
закупівлі але ми все ж звертаємося до
міжнародних організацій і партнерів для
того щоб вони також виділяли гаджети і
для дітей оскільки розуміємо що є діти з
вразливих категорій багатодітних сімей
діти які внутрішньо переміщеними особами
і які для організації так само
дистанційного змішаного навчання
потребують персонального гаджету і про
це ми сьогодні поспілкуємося з нашими
двома гостями це роман Грищук народний
депутат України і член нашого
профільного комітету з освіти науки та
інновації а також Оленою Бондаренко
співзасновницею громадської організації
батьки SOS колеги
Вітаю да Доброго дня Добрий день Так
Доброго дня дуже радий вас бачити тож
почнемо з запитанням як на вашу думку
потрібно забезпечувати дітей
персональними гаджетами який спосіб
вибрати ще раз наголошую для тих
глядачів які лише під'єдналися що ми
маємо можливість такого інтерактиву Ви
можете так само на це запитання
відповідати на нашому сайті
тож розпочнемо з вас Олена
так на ваше прохання до прохання ваших
колег ми провели ціле дослідження в себе
в групі тому що
це питання Ясно що ви його не можете
розв'язати Скажімо так от геть галопом
бігом і сюди вирішити і наші батьки коли
обговорювали це питання абсолютно
зрозуміли чому І заодно зрозуміло що
таке рішення влади і наскільки складно
їх приймати Тобто було два питання
більше два варіанти відповіді на питання
як краще передати ці ноутбуки які
надійдуть для школярів України Я краще
їх передати дітям варіантів два дарувати
дітям особисто віддавати їм у власність
або передати на баланс закладу освіти а
вони вже будуть передавати учням в
користування
нам ще додавали учасники групи такі
варіанти як передати грішми але ми
розуміємо що наразі про це не йдеться
грошей немає є ноутбуки або їх або
нічого так от за результатами цього
опитування взяли участь в опитуванні
1753 особи на останній момент кілька
хвилин тому коли я дивилася і результати
такі щоб передати школі радять
67% учасників опитування а віддати дітям
подарувати їх безпосередньо дітям це
29%. ну і один відсоток ті що кажуть що
краще віддати грішно тобто такі
абсолютно вражаючі результати я можу
привітати освітян з тим що такий великий
відсоток який кажуть передати школі
говорить про велику довіру та закладу
освіти але
не менш важливі в цьому опитуванні є ще
коментарі тому що я просила людей
обґрунтувати свою точку зору написати
Чому вони так думають оскільки в нас
група дуже
Як це сказати так заточена на критику
Вони шукають у кожному рішенні якісь
слабкі місця Вони шукають недоліки і що
може піти не так тому в основному от про
недоліки кожного такого рішення я собі
виокремила основні моменти про які
говорили батьки наприклад які я недоліки
рішення передати безпосередньо дітям Ну
тоді школи залишаться знову ж таки без
техніки як і був раніше в них на балансі
є не буде
тоді дітям кажуть ви знаєте тут
розділилась думка чи діти будуть
ставитися краще до цієї техніки тому що
вона їхня власність чи може вони краще
ставились Якби вона була шкільна в них в
користуванні Отут в мене зійшлися думки
тому що абсолютно вважають і ті і ті що
краще коли їхня і так само впевнені
Краще коли чужа тоді краще ставлення
крім того є Ризик що в нас є так звані
неблагополучні родини і якщо техніка
потрапить до цих батьків вони можуть її
просто
втратити заради там алкоголю наркотиків
тощо Але мені здається що таких родин на
щастя в Україні не так багато для того
щоб
оцей сумнів ставити якби як категоричний
і не давати дітям ці ноутбуки
ну власне проти того щоб передати їх
безпосередньо дітям оцей всі аргументи
але значно більше аргументів проти того
щоб передавати їх школі хоча нагадаю
більшість проголосували за те щоб
віддати школі але при тому аргументів
більше проти наприклад ремонт Окей
віддали учню ноутбук він на нього
ламається хто має його ремонтувати це
має бути гарантійний ремонт це мають
бути центри це має принести в школу там
де він його взяв А де тоді школи
візьмуть кошти на ці ремонти тому що в
кожному разі все впреться гроші адже або
треба наймати фахівця або ввести в штат
або укласти якісь партнерські знову ж
таки хто чи є в тому місці в селі чи ще
десь саме ті партнери які поремонтують
саме оцю техніку тобто тоді виникають
проблеми з ремонтом і ми розуміємо що це
буде проблема з дитиною яка залишиться
без ноутбука якщо віддасть його
ремонтувати і велика проблема школи як
його поремонтувати коли він буде готовий
Якщо у власності дитини ми розуміємо що
вона вирішує з батьками цю проблему так
як вважає за потрібне Чи це гарантійний
ремонт чи приватний чи в мене є дядько
який розбирається в комп'ютері
потім на жаль так само говорять про
непрозорої розподіл закладами освіти цих
гаджетів тобто що є такий великий ризик
тому що з такими вже випадками стикалися
і кажуть що напевне що якісь там родичі
будуть з ноутбуками діти які справді
потребують можуть залишитися без них і
насправді Це буде дуже складно
перевірити вимагати там списки вимагати
якби звіти про те наскільки ці люди
потребують ну це теж буде дуже негарно
коли громадськість буде вимагати в
кожної родини звіт А ви достатньо бідні
щоб ми перевірили що ви правильно
отримали цей ноутбук тобто цього теж не
можна дозволяти
потім якщо дитина втратить загубить
розіб'є і так далі Навіть якщо ми будемо
укладати між закладом освіти і цією
родиною Договори про те що є якісь
санкції за збереження цього ноутбука то
виконання цих санкцій та тому що ми
даємо дитині ноутбук тому що в неї немає
грошей її батьків для того щоб його
придбати відповідно в цей родини не буде
грошей на те щоб компенсувати втрату
Тому це все буде просто така паперова
якась тяга мила яка може звичайно
завершитися в суді але ви тоді розумієте
що все суспільство буде тикати пальцями
в ту школу в тих суддів і так далі що як
у вас взагалі піднялася рука це робити
наступне діти переселенці тобто
внутрішньо переміщення особи Я маю на
увазі це вони навчаються в школі в
Харкові дистанційно і вони в цей час
знаходяться десь у Львівській області
якщо ми даємо ці ноутбуки школі в
Харкові то ті діти учні цієї школи які
зараз знаходяться у Львівській області
Вони їх не отримують тому що вони не
можуть поїхати в Харків під вогонь щоб
отримати ці ноутбуки бо вони знаходяться
там навіть відносно безпечній території
тому ті школи де справді дітям потрібні
ці ноутбуки насправді не зможуть їх
роздати своїм дітям в їхні діти приїхали
по всьому світу
наступне на який період видаватимуться
ці ноутбуки якщо йдеться про рік ну
знову ж таки ми пам'ятаємо що зараз
будь-який гаджет - це річ абсолютно
особисто з власними налаштуваннями
паролями архівами і так далі
на рік що буде через рік знову годувати
тій дитині тому що ми ж розуміємо що у
нас діти більшість дітей це був дій які
отримають ці ноутбуки Це ті які будуть
навчатися в школі ще більше ніж один рік
Тобто це учні з першого там по 10 класі
це надовго так поки першачки дійдуть до
11-го класу вони вже забудуть що в них
ці ноутбуки колись були тому що вони
будуть настільки застарілі що вони вже
їх не будуть використовувати давати
тільки на рік знову ж таки як їх потім
знайти цих дітей які по всій Україні
навчалися дистанційно щоб вони в ту
школу їх повернули хто буде проводити
технічно оцінку справності повернутого
ноутбука в якому він стані скільки там
вірусів чи здатен чи працюватиме він
далі чи можна його взагалі ще комусь
надати тому я вже не кажу про те як
зараз вчителі реагують на цю ініціативу
тому що вчителі от оці вони вже їх
розуміють Вони знають що таке майно яке
треба прийняти на баланс яке треба
кудись потім списати на якій підставі де
шукати матеріальна відповідальність
тобто для них найкращий варіант Окей
давайте нам ноутбуки ми їх гарненько
заховаємо в шафу щоб їх ніхто не чіпав і
щоб нам голову Потім ними не морочили
оце в принципі
я ж кажу такий такий от парадокс тобто
більшість батьків проголосувала за те
щоб віддати в школі але найбільша
аргументів за те щоб школам їх не
передавати а віддати безпосередньо дітям
тому я вам дуже співчуваю співчуваю тим
людям таким доведеться ухвалювати це
рішення але в кожному разі це
обговорення показало що наше суспільство
ви знаєте воно спробувало подумати разом
з вами як вам це все робити і воно вже
має сприйняти як те рішення яке ви
приймете Значно краще з меншим опором
Скажімо так
Дякую Олена Дякую вам за проведене
опитування і я дуже-дуже з вами
погоджуюся про те що навіть якщо ці 2000
людей задумувалися над тим що це
запитання існує і щоб у нього немає
правильної відповіді це вже
дуже-дуже гарно романи Розкажи будь
ласка свою думку або свій досвід Я знаю
що ти також займаєшся питанням
забезпечення дітей гаджетами можливо
поділишся своєю точкою зору
Дмитро і всіх глядачів Вітаю Дякую за
запрошення пані Олена дуже цікаво була
аналітика Я два тижні тому разом з Ромою
акцент - це журналістами Української
правди запустили проект 500 планшетів і
ноутбуків для дітей внутрішньо
переміщених осіб до 1 вересня тому мені
надзвичайно близькі були ті аргументи та
обговорення яке яке про яке ви говорили
ми обрали схему за яку проголосувало
менше Але яка працює Мені здається краще
це видавати безпосередньо дітям коли ми
оголошуємо грандфайдингову компанію Ми
кажемо чітко дивіться ми збираємо кошти
для того щоб передати дитині в епоху
власність що це за дитина у нас є центри
роботи з двопою які проходять
верифікацію цих дітей які кажуть цій
дитині потрібно тобто роль центр вказати
ось дитинка вона у нас в центрі ми
дійсно знаємо що їй потрібно ми
передаємо просто отримується дитина акт
для того щоб все дитина дитина отримує
люди які донатять на це кошти вони
розуміють що от нас от така схема
причому друга про школу вона може
існувати Просто мені цікаво було якби ми
поставили питання батьки У вас є ноутбук
який чи планшет і ви його передаєте ви
його безпосередньо дитині дасте Чи ви
дасте директору школи я думаю там було
було б зворотнє історія трішки назад
повернувся мені надзвичайно приємно що
ми зараз обговорюємо такого роду
проблему Але такого роду питання а не
питання що держава полягає всіх
забезпечити І це дуже добре що Дмитро
одразу сказав у нас немає коштів
по-друге Навіть якби були кошти треба
було говорити чи всім потрібна є родини
які можуть забезпечити своїх дітей
засоби для навчання є велика категорія
дітей які зараз
кончені Ці планшети і ноутбуки чому ми
зупинились на дітях внутрішнього
переміщених осіб велика частина із них
там втратила домівки або домівках
залишилися Ці планшети або велика
кількість це що вже після того після
того як ми запустили кампанію нам
розказали велика кількість діток які
виїжджали з батьками з окупованих
територій в них просто на блокпостах
окупанти забирали все там по телефону
ноутбуки і планшети і вони навіть маючи
їх Вони залишилися без цих засобів для
навчання враховуючи що навчання буде в
онлайн або в комбінованому форматі ви
навіть якщо тільки офлайн планшет для
дитини і або ноутбук це надважливо зараз
наш час Тому
або доєднуйтесь до нашої ініціативи або
робіть свою ініціативу кооперуйтеся з
фондами якщо є у вас можливість передати
безпосередньо дитині планшет чи ноутбук
дитині які потрібно робіть я думаю тут
акцент якраз на саме громадян всередині
країни або на якісь великі фонди які там
умовно не 13 на армію або не можуть
використовувати кошти на армію але з
радістю використати це на освіту через
маленькі оці от благодійні фонди чи
маленькі ініціативи по-перше вони що
дають вони дають оперативність Тобто ми
зібрали там певну суму коштів купили 20
планшетів сьогодні завтра вони вже є в
дітях друге це це ну тобто якби це
робила Держава це довго процедура по
закупівлі по всьому іншому друга точніше
третє те що
входячи в колаборацію там з певними
магазинами вони можуть давати таку
знижку і щоб оці знижці там ніхто б не
ноутбук а вони бачать вже і планшети
бачиш що цю ініціативу підтримуючи її
вони дають третє ми На Відміну Від
міністерства освіти можемо ну або якоїсь
якоїсь офіційного органу можемо сказати
друзі якщо у вас є там беушні чи ще щось
які працюючі які ми можемо кваліфікувати
шановні дійсно працюємо ми готові ці цій
дитині передати Я не знаю як би це можна
було робити бюрократичним шляхом а
шляхом таким воно також закриває потребу
тому що найосновніше це закрити потребу
щоб дитина до 1 вересня могла онлайн
навчатися Бо коли мені кажуть що там
сім'я і діти є один телефон у мами і
вони у мами беруть телефон для того щоб
виходити в режим на уроках по черзі так
немає бути Ми маємо все докласти для
того щоб все ж таки у дітей були засоби
для навчання
дякую
Дякую Романе я тут також Хочу додати що
Ми навіть як Міністерство з всіма нашими
партнерами не маємо однієї єдиної моделі
співпраці звісно там коли ми кажемо про
велику кількість ноутбуків для вчителів
то ці ноутбуки передаються на баланс
закладів освіти і заклади освіти як або
їх засновники вирішують яким саме чином
ефективніше використати цю техніку і на
нашу думку що Звісно якщо це
вмотивований енергійний директор який
знає яким чином ефективно використати цю
техніку то в такому ідеальному світі цей
варіант точно більше ефективний тому що
він більш гнучкий щось може змінитися
мета використання цієї техніки може
змінитися але в реальному світі ми
бачимо коментарі про які казала Олена і
є купа підводних каменів і купа різних
навіть емоційних аргу
так наприклад спільно з компанією Acer
Ми вирішили ті 100 ноутбуків які вони
хотіли подарувати в Україні подарувати
особисто тим вчителям які виїхали з
Маріуполя і щоб ці ноутбуки залишилися
просто за ними не
закладами освіти
а в таке самостійне користування Дякую
вам що доєдналися до нашої сьогоднішньої
зустрічі І дякую вам за вашу чудову
роботу тоді ми переходимо вже до
наступного блоку нашої сьогоднішньої
конференції Антоніна будь ласка вам
слово
Дякую і перш ніж ми презентуємо другий
блок хотілося б озвучити її
продемонструвати і проміжні підсумки із
того опитування яке ми організовуємо для
налаштування взаємодії прошу увага на
екран поки що відповідь на актуальне
запитання як краще забезпечувати учнів
гаджетами ви бачите і робите вибір таким
чином що майже 80%, що треба передати
все ж таки закладу освіти і тільки 21 що
подарувати учням батькам особисто а для
того щоб продовжити взаємодіяти разом з
нами і відповідати на ще додаткові
запитання у прямому ефірі ми нагадуємо
що в супровід заходу у нас є сайт і
qr-код на нього Ви можете поставити на
паузу відсканувати саме зараз чи в описі
під відео всі запитання
відкриваються зі сторінки вза дія і
наступне питання яке ми будемо з вами
разом опрацьовувати це як же ж буде
організоване навчання з першого вересня
А у нас на часі як і зазначив пан Дмитро
робота нашого блоку другого і з назвою
цифровий контент і я із задоволенням
хочу запросити до слова пані Зою Литвин
і ми
Прошу пані Зоя Доброго дня вітання
колеги рада всіх бачити і рада що попри
всі обставини традиція серпневих
конференцій продовжується це важливо
доки наші Захисники на передовій
боронять наші сьогодні дуже важливо
продовжувати боронити наше завтра і
власне це якраз задача освітнього фронту
Тому зараз я хочу поділитися з вами
такими основними основним контентом який
ми з командою в партнерстві з
міністерством з різними організаціями
готуємо для вас і щоб це полегшувало вам
тримати освітній фронт
Якщо можна я зараз поділюся екраном Так
напевне легше мені буде
розповідати і демонструвати і хочу
почати з нашого такого продукту Яким є
платформа освіта НАУ
чому вона важлива тому що кожна дитина
має право на якісну освіту і це ключовий
інструмент для того щоб наші діти могли
реалізувати себе творити кращу версію
себе в майбутньому і краще версію
українського суспільства
за врахунками усіd 8 місяців пандемії
ковіду призвели до таких втрат в
середньому в 20 балів
освітніх системах і зокрема в Україні а
якщо говорити про статистику
всесвітнього банку їхнього освітнього
відділення то
рік дистанційної освіти
потенційно може зменшити доходи наших
дітей і відповідно економіки країни на
мінус 10%. в Україні війна тримає вже
майже 6 місяців і ми маємо зробити все
щоб мінімізувати ці наслідки
недостатнього доступу до освіти для
наших дітей це не буде ідеально але ми
маємо робити все що в наших силах Ну і
власне для цього ми створили для
Міністерства освіти і науки України за
партнерства з фондом юнісеф це фонд
Дитячий фонд ООН платформа освіта на на
кого вона розрахована це
освітні адміністрації це вчителі та це
батьки тут ви можете побачити інтерфейс
нашої платформи і основна задача цієї
платформи бути таким порадником 24/7 і
дати відповіді на всі питання
які стосуються освіти під час війни ви
можете побачити які речі питань покриває
платформа це навчання за кордоном це
питання безпеки мінної безпеки це
психологічна підтримка Ну я маю додати
що платформа оновлюється щотижня тому що
і ситуація безпекова військово
оновлюється щотижня і оперативно всі
зміни які
продукує комітет освіти держава
Міністерство освіти вони на платформі
відображаються Ну якщо говорити про
батьків також де б вони зараз не
знаходились на цій платформі вони можуть
знайти відповіді на всі запитання як
вони можуть продовжувати навчання в
Україні дистанційно як вони можуть
допомогти дитині з дозвіллям під час
війни який є поруч гуртки і можливості
для дитини продовжувати отой зв'язок з
Україною будь-які юридичні питання тому
це чудовий порадник користуйтеся ним ну
і ще важлива така окрема ініціатива яка
скоро з'явиться на цій же самій
платформі вона зветься спільно до
навчання взагалі робоча назва цієї
ініціативи була Back to School назад до
школи але ми розуміємо що цей рік буде
не зовсім назад до школи як до якогось
фізичного простору до якого Ми звикли
для когось це буде екстернат для когось
це буде дистанційне навчання вдома ну і
тому назва проекту змінилася це проект
Міністерства освіти
офісу першої Леді і так само за
підтримки юнісеф його було реалізовано
даний проект дасть відповідь освітянам
батькам І
вчителям щодо того як діти можуть
повертатися до навчання під час війни і
це буде навчання в школі навчання
дистанційне навчання екстренатне і також
трохи про дозвілля під час війни
платформа буде покривати Перепрошую
багато питань
ну від того чим зайняти дітей в
бомбисховищах які можуть бути ігри щоб
їх стабілізувати до якихось вимог і
протоколів які згодяться освітянам і це
все буде дуже зручно зібрано в одному
місці так що користуйтеся платформою Ну
і невеличке інтро яке я маю зробити до
наступного спікера це також про контент
для навчання під час війни і це власне
платформа всеукраїнська школа онлайн
напевно багато з вас вже з тією
платформою знайомі і
це такий проект який ми зробили для
українського уряду під час пандемії
ковід і звичайно Ніхто з нашої команди
не очікував що цей проект стане в нагоді
за ще страшніших обставин ніж пандемія
проект має чудові результати його мета
привести українських учнів перед екраном
де вони побачать найкращих вчителів
України і платформа власне перекриває
навчальний контент для середньої старшої
школи
скоро це вже буде повністю перекритий
навчальний рік з 5 по 11 клас на кінець
минулого навчального року ми мали на
платформі
489 тисяч українських дітей та вчителів
які регулярно на ній займалися і вони
приєднувалися зі 120 країн світу для
того щоб продовжувати навчання
тримати свій зв'язок з Україною і знати
що попри війну нашій країні важливо
продовжувати освіту цих дітей і це такий
безпечний куточок де вони можуть
продовжувати свої довоєнні рутини
продовжувати своє навчання і відповідно
вірити в своє майбутнє так само як і Ми
віримо в їхнє майбутнє користуйтеся будь
ласочка освіта НАУ користуйтеся
цією можливістю
користуйтеся проектом спільно до
навчання і звичайно платформою вишио для
змішаного навчання для домашніх завдань
для навчання дистанційного Дякую за
увагу і ми з вами ще сьогодні побачимось
[музика]
чудово Вітаю вас всіх шановні освітяни
Шановні колеги радий нагоді долучитися
до наших серпневої конференції І власне
продовжуючи тему виступу у пані зоо
Литвин Я хотів би ще трішки таких
штрихів додати до тематики всеукраїнська
школа онлайн Річ у тім що проєкт
всеукраїнська школа онлайн стартував
спочатку як телевізійна версія і тому що
мало педагогів зараз з різних регіонів
України Ще й не знають про те що це
платформа стабільна режим до якої
доступу 24/7 ми можемо долучатися до
найкращих методичних навчальних
матеріалів в різних ролях І зараз я як
учитель української мови та літератури
який зокрема і є автором одного з курсів
в рамках проєкту всеукраїнська школа
онлайн і як практикуючи вчитель який
зараз готується до нового навчального
року в умовах війни
тому вам трішки розказати про потенціал
та можливості платформи всеукраїнська
школа онлайн Можливо ми дещо ще не
знаємо можливо мене щось не звертало
увагу а зараз ми спробуємо з вами на
цьому акцентувати насамперед що я хочу
сказати що
платформа всеукраїнська школа онлайн
вона є дуже зручно Тобто ми можемо зайти
на цю платформу і через свій гаджет
наприклад ноутбук чи комп'ютер чи
планшет можемо ми також і скачати на
свій мобільний телефон є спеціальним
мобільне застосунок тобто можемо з собою
платформу переносити в будь-якому
фізичному просторі платформа максимально
персоналізовано перед тим як
реєструватися або обираєте роль е-е свою
на цій платформи чи ви учитель Чи ви
учень учениця що ви слухать слухачка це
курси і ви можете максимально просто
зареєструватися максимально легко
контролювати свої пересування свій
прогрес на цій платформі в принципі на
сайті в шо є дуже багато тому методичних
відео як використовувати платформу
працює служба підтримки тобто в принципі
такі технічні питання навряд чи стану
для вас такою перепоною ми бачимо на
платформі класи з 5 по 11-й і у нас для
цих класів створено курси з основних
шкільних предметів ви як учитель Можете
самі зареєструватися на цій платформі та
використовувати матеріали того чи іншого
курсу і ви можете також зареєструвати
своїх учнів сприяти тому що вони
зареєструвались на платформі і
використовували матеріали цієї платформи
розгляньмо детальніше що у нас є
наприклад У нас є курс українська
література 11-й клас якщо ви зайдете на
цю платформу зареєструєтесь ви побачите
тут у нас є і тематика кожного заняття
ви ця тематика ви можете простежити Вона
відповідає календарному плануванню тобто
по суті це електронна версія вашого
навчання в тому першому класі і ви Якщо
ваш учень ваша учениця пропустила ту чи
іншу тему ви можете використовувати
матеріалу платформу в якості матеріалу
для повторення узагальнення або
самостійного опрацювання матеріалу учням
чи ученицями Ви також можете
використовувати ці матеріали в якості
онлайн навчання в якості дистанційного
навчання або в якості організації
змішаного навчання Ми всі з вами чудово
розуміємо що цей навчальний рік 2022-23
є непростим як у кажучи Тому ми маємо
використовувати різноманітні платформи
різноманітні потенціал який у нас є для
того щоб зробити процес навчання
максимально приємним максимально
ефективним і максимально знаєте таким
константним тобто щось має бути постійне
і власне кажучи якщо використовувати
матеріали платформу всеукраїнська школа
онлайн Ми зберігаємо ось цей принцип
тяглості ось цей принцип стабільності
для учнів для учениць незважаючи на
якісь певні сигнали які виникатимуть
Протягом цього
кожен курс Кожен урок складається з
кількох матеріалів Наприклад ми бачимо
маленьке відео тривалістю 7-10 хвилин
орієнтовно побудована за принципом
мікронавчання одне відео Одна тема Також
ми в матеріалах до уроку бачимо Ну і
текст суфлеру до власне відео нашого
матеріалу у нас є нагода у опція
завантажити конспект а також дати
відповіді на тестові запитання які є на
платформі їх в основному є 5 також є 10
питань якщо це підсумкова тема то учні
можуть скористатися цією опцією дати
відповіді на ті чи інші питання плюс
конспект Ви також можете завантажити і
переслати його учням ученицям для
їхнього самостійного опрацювання і це в
принципі створює такий знаєте потенціал
для того щоб ви максимально фантазували
максимальну вигадували якісь нові
підходи для того щоб взаємодіяти з
учнями максимально комфортно і
максимально якісно тобто платформа
всеукраїнська школамен дозволяє по-перше
організовувати змішане дистанційне
навчання ми можемо створювати
перевернутий клас колу учні самостійно
дивляться вдома відео працюють конспект
а потім на онлайн уроці протягом 45
хвилин ми максимально практично Працюємо
з дітьми і перевіряємо закріпимо цей
матеріал також учні можуть самостійно
зареєструватися на платформі і
дистанційно опрацьовувати матеріали
відео конспект джерела додаткові
підготовки тести і також там у нас є
додаткові матеріали для вчителів та
учнів знову таки ми можемо їх вільно
використовувати можемо їх викачувати
безкоштовно і потім далі переслати дітям
як варіант таке може бути діти
опрацьовують тести під час онлайн уроків
я думаю це зайве знаєте джерело для
підготовки ми можемо це використовувати
це матеріали ну чудових найкращих
вчителів України які доклали багато
зусиль для підготовки написання уроків і
виведення їх на цю платформу
також можна використовувати платформу
вшо для проєктної діяльності Річ у тім
що багато уроків там уже є певні
завдання які можна використовувати як
проєкти Тобто можна підглянути
піддивитися щось учителів і запозичити
якісь методи запозичити якісь теми
запозичити якісь прийоми і запропонувати
виконувати ці проєкти дітям Ну і також
ще раз підкреслюємо використання
навчальних матеріалів на платформі є
абсолютно вільне і демократичне Тобто ви
можете перекинути рекомендувати учня
переглянути відео Наприклад те яке ви
хочете вважаєте що воно може додати
додатковий там потенціал вашим учням для
вивчення того чи іншого матеріалу ви
можете використовувати конспекти і ви
можете також адресувати учнів на
виконання тестів на цій платформі
останнє оновлення і це дуже класний
такий ресурс - це функція створення Мій
кабінет коли вчитель може запросити
конкретних учнів конкретних учениць на
курс тобто він копію це матеріал
наприклад візьмемо українська література
11 клас він копіює дані курси
всеукраїнського школи онлайн на
платформі і до цього курсу Мають доступ
конкретні учнів конкретні учениці
конкретного класу з якими вчитель
взаємодія в межах населеного пункту або
в межах онлайн Навчання тут у нас є
опція створити і певні обговорення Коли
ми можемо з учнями певні питання
обговорювати тут ми можемо також
простежувати і контроль прогрес учнів
тобто вони опрацьовують матеріали вони
дають відповіді на тести і ми бачимо
наскільки вдало вони станом на сьогодні
володіють матеріалом наскільки вони
ефективно дали відповіді на ту чи іншу
тему на ті чи інші запитання це дозволяє
вчителеві конкретно в режимі свого
спілкування зі своїми учнями та
ученицями моніторити прогрес свого класу
і Можливо десь Ще раз щось повторити
Можливо десь ще вказати учням що ми цим
опрацювати той чи інший матеріал і так
далі тобто функція Мій кабінет - це по
суті ну такий віртуальний кабінет на
платформі всеукраїнська школа онлайн до
якого має доступ конкретні клас
конкретні учні учениці і їхні вчителі
або вчителька і це На мою думку дуже
класне джерело Для додаткової такої
активності взаємодії між учителем та
учнями а в наш час сьогодні це дуже
важливо коли учитель та учні мають
нагоду взаємодія
Звичайно що за 5 хвилин я не можу
розказати про весь потенціал платформи
Але можу сказати що платформа має
доступну комунікацію з усіма нами ми
можемо там скачати ми можемо переглянути
методичні рекомендації для вчителів та
вчителів різними мовами причому для того
щоб використовувати максимально весь
потенціал нашої платформи і я ще раз
можу лише порадити нам вчителям звернути
увагу на платформу всеукраїнська школа
онлайн зайти розглянути ці курсу у нас є
ще декілька тижнів до старту нового
навчального року і це Чудова нагода
спробувати потенціал цей перевірити на
практиці тобто спробуйте зареєструватись
на ці платформи і зареєструватися разом
із дітьми і це дозволить і нам учителям
десь можливо заощаджувати свої сили в
хорошому сенсі цього слова десь
додатково давати ще якісь інші джерела
інформації для наших учнів та учениць і
сумарно це даватиме позитивний ефект для
всіх учасників нашого навчального
процесу я щиро вірю і щиро переконаний
що ця платформа всеукраїнська школа
онлайн Вона дозволяє нам бути сильнішим
а сьогодні в наш час ми маємо бути
сильними ми маємо готуватися до викликів
нового навчального року ми маємо бути
цифровий в сфері цифрової грамотності
активними та сильними і використовувати
різні джерела інформації Одним із таких
це якраз всеукраїнська школа онлайн але
я також впевнений що і нові платформи і
нові застосунки у нас поступово
з’являються і будуть з'являтися Протягом
цього навчального року і я знаю що пані
Зоя Литвин засновниця громадської спілки
освіторія та інноваційної новопечерської
школи знає ще більше інформації про нові
проєкти про нові ініціативі в галузі
цифрової технології в галузі цифрової
освіти які вже готові або готуються до
запуску в цьому навчальному році
Дякую Артур надзвичайно така натхненна
розповідь про вишиву і як
використовувати Цей дивовижний
інструмент а я справді хочу розказати
про ще один чудовий інструмент тому що
вшо Про яке ви щойно почули воно
покриває контент за державним навчальним
планом для середньої та старшої школи
залишається питання Що робити зі школою
початковою Тому що
їм теж потрібно навчатися цікаво сучасну
інтерактивно і цього року через війну
Також потрібно мати додаткові
інструменти цифрові додатковий контент
Ну і власне тут Я маю честь вам
представити проєкт який зараз
надзвичайно активно розробляється і
Forest стартує до старту навчального
року які називаються вивчаю Не чекаю це
проект зроблений громадською спілкою
освітою спільно з міжнародною
організацією з її нідерландським офісом
а також звичайно з міністерством освіти
і науки і це буде ось та чудова освітня
зброя для вчителів початкової школи це
мобільне застосунок Який є геміфікований
цікавий інтерактивний і він розрахований
на дітей з перших по четвертий клас і
він перекриває навчальний план щодо двох
дисциплін література читання та
математика
зі свого досвіду можу сказати що
геніфікація - це чудовий інструмент який
набагато підвищує навчальні досягнення
учнів як старші так середній а тим
більше в початковій школі ну і власне
тут я хочу передати слово кураторці
цього проекту з боку нідерландського
офісу міжнародної компанії точніше
організації
з якою ми тісно співпрацюємо Kate My
oner to do is yours and
всім добрий день для мене особлива честь
сьогодні бути з усіма вами я не можу вас
бачити на екрані але я знаю що ви тут і
слухаєте вітаю
Life
[музика]
отже розпочнімо давайте поговоримо про
це Чому це так важливо чому цей проєкт є
таким важливим освіторія та Міністерство
освіти та науки підтримують освітян
України в настільки складні важкі часи
Happy
Я дуже вдячна що мене запросили Я і Мої
колеги Будемо робити все можливе аби вас
підтримати
Отже перейдімо до того чим ми власне
займаємося на практиці
Як ви вже чули від попередніх спікерів
ми працюємо над всеукраїнською
онлайн-школою
віліс For childing The For але тут ми
фокусуємо нашу увагу
особливо на розробці матеріалів для
дітей першого класу початкових класів
Space education
Це ці матеріали засновані на навчальній
програмі наданою міністерством освіти та
науки України
і вони спеціально були оброблені над
ними було проведено роботу освіторією
щоб навчання відбувалося за власним
темпом та у автономному режимі для дітей
молодшого шкільного віку
gaming of the
gating
Як ви вже чули і сподіваюся скоро
дізнаєтеся на практиці ці матеріали
адаптовані в ігровій формі аби навчання
для дітей було цікавим та веселим to
US із
І що особлива важливо то розроблені нами
матеріали є адаптовані до культурного та
освітнього контексту учнів
ukrainiannes the party
Ukrainian childing and Access
це завдяки звісно у роботі з нашими
партнерами а також долучаються до
розробки українських діти українських
художників
і дуже скоро ви зможете трошечки
шматочок побачити зазирнути як це
виглядає
ukrainess і навіть тут у куточку слайду
ви зараз бачите відомого українського
шеф-кухаря мабуть і ви знаєте як його
звати
contextiles та Main the scase have to be
flexible in
і щодо контекстуального підходу тут ми
особливо увагу приділяємо тому щоб
вчителі в сучасних українських умовах
мали
опцію гнучкості у роботі з матеріалом
інколи діти будуть перебувати у школах
інколи в якихось інших місцях локаціях
інколи з ними разом буде вчитель а
подекуди його не буде Over
і дуже важливо слідкувати за прогресом
за тим як розвиваються успіхи кожного
учня або учениці це важливо для усіх
вчителів котрих я знаю
and
finalls і дуже важливо щоб цей проєкт
був доступний що дуже ключовим є
моментом для українських дітей і в
Україні і за кордоном
давайте подивимось що ми розробляємо
World
Star
War of Ukraine
коли діти входять в цей ігровий світ
вони бачать на обкладинці оцей світ
України створений художниками Я думаю ви
все Бачите на слайді
so in the Fest to you
і для кожного року розроблено свій
окремий ігровий світ для першого року це
оцей чудовий український краєвид Seconds
на другому слайді другий рік це такий
міський пейзаж
у човні
і діти обрали особливий інший третій
ігровий світ для третього року Який теж
виглядає дуже привабливою
Спейс Feeling А на четвертий рік дещо
фантазійне таке подекуди космічне світ в
якому вони перебуватимуть
Action
Access O childing accessey application
розроблено так щоб діти могли зайти у
застосунок або з планшету або з
мобільного телефону
ми вибрали планшет оскільки вони дуже
добре працюють для молодших дітей
Отже що ще ми можемо побачити у цьому
світі
в цьому світі існують персонажі і
парочку з них ви бачите зараз
perfection
у кожного з героїв з персонажів є
професія і є мрія побудувати будинок
який відповідає їхній професії…
і коли діти проробляють роботу виконують
завдання про які розкажу пізніше
і по ходу виконання цих завдань діти
отримують нагороди і цей будинок
розбудовується зростає і наприклад
ветеринар отримує свій будиночок з
місцем для собаки для
котикаємо very stronly Little
в процесі спільного створення застосунку
з українськими дітьми Ми побачили
наскільки сильний їм подобається тварини
тому по всьому застосунку ви побачите
багато тваринок в якості нагород
жується
це все чудово але я думаю у вас як у
вчителів виникає питання То як же діти
будуть власне навчатися
на кожному відрізку шляху
lessons є набір уроків
перший це відеоурок
childing conce
imagine Edition
там Діти вивчають дізнаються певної
концепт отримують первинне уявлення про
якесь поняття
і Після перегляду є низка міні-ігор
низка вправ до яких може дитина перейти
одразу
домініки
у цих вправах
концепції розбито на менші легші для
сприйняття і дитина може їх
попрактикувати по ходу
childing of the
тут дуже ґрунтовний підхід до
запам'ятовування та вивчення так щоб
максимально гарантувати що дитина
зрозуміла та засвоїла
матеріалs in Every Class you hative
Levels Have
you proble і ви вчителі як ніхто інший
знає те що в кожному класі є дітки які
йдуть швидше і дітки які йдуть по війні
що у кожного свій темп засвоєння
Performance
[музика]
Отже у нас такий адаптивний підхід в
якому кількість вправ є адаптивною і
залежить від успіхів учня бо чиниться
У нас є відмінність між практикою або
так званою роботою без помилок
із
стейк in the Tide and
тут коли дитина виконує вправу і
припускається помилки Вона може виконати
вправу повторно тобто помилка
дозволяється
і вони можуть повторювати виконувати ці
вправи аж доки не діють до певного
проміжного тестування всередині гри а
літера
і коли все проходить зрештою добре
дитина отримує нагороду отримає нового
персонажа або переходить до нового рівня
гри back
і ми розробили це застосунок так щоб
дитина отримувала позитивне підкріплення
та підтримку походу проходження уроків
Sorry of
звісно для нас величезна честь розпочати
цю роботу разом з освіторією та
міністерством освіти та науки
ми працювали дуже серйозна та ґрунтовно
і маю надію що вже у вересні можна буде
очікувати запуск продукту з мінімально
необхідним наповненням
і там буде контент для всіх чотирьох
початкових класів
звісно там буде більшість але не весь
контент він буде оновлюватися і восени
також буде і математична частина
контенту готова у застосунку
і оновлення будуть також регулярно
поступати після завантаження
але найважливіше для нас буде отримувати
зворотній зв'язок від учителів які
присутні тут сьогодні аби ми могли
покращувати свою роботу по ходу
справиться
і сподіваюся що наступного разу коли ми
побачимося ви вже всі на практиці
спробуєте цей застосунок і зможете
поділитися своїми думками у зворотньому
А тим часом бажаю вам усього найкращого
у підготовці до нового навчального року
дуже вам дякую
Дякую колеги і ми Продовжуємо роботу
нашої локації і Наразі ще одна
презентація цифрового контенту яку мені
особливо приємно наразі представляти
Отже я як сертифікований тренер Google
producation хотіла б на розгляд
освітянської спільноти представити ті
матеріали які підготувала Google Україна
для того щоб допомагати українським
вчителям викладати Як ви бачите на моєму
екрані публікація на спеціальному
офіційному блозі Google України і
заголовком допомагаємо українським
вчителям продовжувати викладати де
викладений інформація щодо співпраці
допомоги
майбутніх
відповідної ініціативи і з різними
пристроями і якщо ми говоримо про
цифровий контент варто обов'язково
згадати про YouTube платформу яка має
назву навчання і створена для того щоб
українські учні віком від 13 до 17 років
могли знайти освітній контент який
допоможе їм у навчанні всі ресурси які
ми використовуємо сьогодні під час
роботи нашого заходу ми передамо вам
через спеціальну сторінку яку
презентуємо трошки пізніше а Наразі я б
хотіла презентувати безпосередньо
перехід Як ви бачите що за активним
покликанням відкривається
youtube-канал із назвою навчання де є
величезний обсяг матеріалів який є
систематизований як за класами так і за
навчальними дисциплінами чи напрямками
головна сторінка угорі містить
відповідний добірки на які можна
підписатися як в комплексі на оновлення
які відбуваються на цьому каналі і
надходження нових відкритих відео так і
за класами
Подивіться скільки систематизованої
впорядкованої інформації від освітян це
і рекомендація і мови напрямки різні для
підготовки і все це списки відтворення
які мають надзвичайно велику кількість
відео для вас весь контент був
систематизований представлений Наприклад
якщо ви відкриєте а й підпишетесь на
добірку для 11 класу то ви бачите
добірки відео які були відкритими і з
ресурсами всеукраїнська школа онлайн а
далі всі предмети за якими ведеться
викладання у такому класі для вас щоб ви
могли працювати із такими навчальними
відео і ваші учні разом або в повному
забезпеченні всіма матеріалами у таких
складних для країни часи я ж маю
переходити до наступної
тільки і із задоволенням хочу передати
слово і представити пані Катерину Супрун
яка продовжить нашу сесію і розповість
представить також дуже важливий напрямок
як унікальні можливості для закладів
вищої освіти прошу Дякую дуже антоно
Вітаю всіх слухачів всіх освітян і
задоволенням розкажу трохи більше що
стосується
цифрового контенту і унікальних
можливостей які команди Міністерства
освіти і науки України
забезпечила для закладів вищої освіти
України Отже після початку
повномасштабного вторгнення одним з
питань яке постало перед системою вищої
освіти в тому числі було питання
цифрового контенту дуже багато студентів
викладачів адміністраторів закладів
вищої освіти були переміщення в той чи
інший те чи інше місто те чи іншу країну
а отже це ми не мали права не
забезпечити безперервність освітнього
процесу І звісно забезпечити цифровий
контент для цього для цього вже в перший
тиждень війни Наша команда Міністерства
освіти і науки України звернулась до
топових онлайн провайдерів неформальної
освіти і з проханням по-перше
забезпечити санкційну політику щодо РФ і
по-друге забезпечити підтримку наших
вишів в результаті цих звернень і
активної комунікації декілька з платформ
забезпечили найбільше охоплення і
найбільшою підтримку для наших
університетів і про цю підтримку Я
сьогодні хотіла б розказати
першою такою платформою яка найперше
відгукнулася на наш заклик про допомогу
стала корсера як ви бачите ця платформа
забезпечила санкції щодо РФ щодо
припинення доступу до контенту заборону
реєстрації а також припинила подальша
співпраці з російськими установами в той
же час корсет надала дуже безпрецедентну
підтримку Україні було відкрито більше
семи тисяч курсів Абсолютно безкоштовно
для всіх закладів вищої освіти України
це 7 тисяч курсів в рамках програми
корсевих кемпус які орієнтовані саме на
здобувачів вищої освіти крім того
курсера розширила свою безкоштовну
програму підтримки яка вже була в них
наявності рефера retages для тих
некомерційних організацій які надають
підтримку Вже зокрема і українським
громадянам а також запустила
безкоштовний онлайн-курс мічиганського
університету про приторгнення яке
відбулось в Україну з РФ Як ви бачите
наразі ми вже досягли гарних результатів
до корсевих підключено більше 300
закладів вищої освіти ще 271 заклад
знаходиться в процесі підключення
запрошено до корсевих більше 40 тисяч
студентів вже 16 з половиною з них є
активними користувачами платформи
розпочали більше 48 тисяч курсів успішно
завершили 31 тисячу з них ми маємо певну
категорію які завершили вже більш як два
курси а саме 6000 таких активних
студентів
у співпраці з компанією corsera ми
провели спеціальний вебінар про
можливості платформи які вона надає для
України і за лінком в цій презентації ви
можете детальніше ознайомитися з
можливостями курсера
другою платформою яка прийшла на
допомогу сталу в людині він так само
припинив подальшу співпрацю з
організаціями з РФ і заборонив продаж
своїх курсів в Росії людині відкрив
більше 7000 безкоштовних онлайн-курсів
для закладів вищої освіти України ці
7000 курсів є топ-3 і входять в топ-3
маркет place to me тобто є курсами з
найвищою якістю і найбільшим попитом і
входять в колекцію Business
наразі вже більше 200 закладів вищої
освіти підключені до юдимі запрошено 52
тисячі студентів із них більше 6000 вже
активно працюють на платформі
з юними також проводили свого часу
вебінар і ви можете ознайомитися за
лінком в цій презентації які ж
можливості І в чому ж особливості саме
цієї платформи і саме цього Market
і третій платформою про яку я сьогодні
розкажу є едекс яка також відгукнулася
на прохання Міністерства освіти і науки
допомогти в ці складні часи вони
видалили зі своєї платформи весь контент
курсів який пропонували раніше російські
заклади що освіти і відкрили 1600
безкоштовних онлайн-курсів еддок онлайн
campus від провідних світових установ і
компаній особливістю розгортання едекс в
закладах вищої освіти є те що вони
напряму підписують партнерські угоди і
напряму співпрацюють з закладами вищої
освіти України наразі укладено вже
більше 50 таких год про співпрацю
Отже які ж наразі в нас є проміжні
результати Як ви бачите топ-5 напрямів
які користують з найбільшим попитом
серед студентів України це англійська
мова для Stem програмування продуктове
it проект на менеджмент і дата Science
Саме ці курси цікавлять українських
студентів не більше на корселі та
платформі юдини серед найбільш активних
закладів вищої освіти є заклади з усіх
регіонів України це і київський і
Львівській і харківські заклади і
Сумський Державний Університет а решта
важливо зазначити наступне крім
забезпечення можливості отримання
якісної і безкоштовної освіти цими
топовими платформами комета Міністерства
освіти і науки України також
потребувалося щодо того щоб результати
навчання які студенти здобувають в
рамках цих курсів були їм зараховані у
освітньому процесі для цього у березні
було заарештовано Наказ МОН щодо
визнання результатів
неформальної та інформальної освіти в
системі формальної освіти це порядок
яким можуть керуватися заклади фахової
передвищої та заклади вищої освіти якщо
вони хочуть здобувати і визнавати
результати які їх студенти пройшли на
онлайн-платформах наразі нам
організована робота нашою командою
впровадження з усіма закладами вищої
освіти України щодо визначення
відповідальних осіб які відповідають за
розгортання цих ресурсів ці особи на
місцях консультують викладачів
науково-педагогічних працівників
адміністраторів та студентів і
забезпечують те щоб вони знають про
можливості надані цими топовими
платформами ми маємо тематичні
чати до яких я впевнена що багато з
глядачів сьогодні вже долучено у разі
якщо вас цікавить більше інформації Як
ваш заклад або як ви як студент можете
отримати такі безкоштовні круті
можливості будь ласка пишіть на нашу
електронну пошту І наша команда
впровадження обов'язково вам допоможе
Дуже дякую пані Антоніна
дякую пані Катерино і ми підбиваємо
підсумки роботи нашого другого блоку
наразі на екрані Я представлю ваші
відповіді які будуть узагальнені у
спеціальній діаграмі щодо активного
запитання А як ви організуєте навчання
із 1 вересня будь ласка результати
прямого ефіру у нас на екрані і як ви
бачите що майже 60% це дистанційне
навчання далі змішаний формат і на
третьому місці очне навчання А Я
закликаю всіх глядачів продовжити з нами
взаємодію із співпрацю яку ви можете
здійснити через сайт заходу де на
навігаційні панелі наявна сторінка
взаємодія і ми для вас підготували ще
одне не менш актуальне запитання яке
будемо досліджувати впродовж часу що
залишився отже як ми продовжимо роботу
наступне на часі також повернутися до
програми і зорієнтувати вас у тому Які
ще два блоки у нас передбачені в роботі
такої локації програма на екрані і я маю
розпочати
презентувати інформацію у блоці номер 3
який має назву цифрова компетентність
освітян і задоволенням хотіла б
презентувати центральний ресурс Google в
Україні який має назву навчайте де б ви
не були викликання на нього Я теж
передам або за допомогою qr-кода який ви
бачите на екрані зупиняєте трансляцію
скануєте І ви вже разом з нами можете
досліджувати ці ресурси які постійно
оновлюються є актуальними і надзвичайно
важливими і цей ресурс
представлений у своїй структурі трьома
розділами перша сторінка - це
рекомендації для вчителів де є
актуальні новини тих світових
інструментів які відповідно оздобилися
новими функціями а також короткі
рекомендації як навчати дистанційно за
допомогою відеозучі як управляти
віртуальним класом як зробити уроки
доступними для всіх як заохочувати учнів
і багато іншого а я б хотіла ще
акцентувати увагу на другій сторінці яка
має назву для закладів освіти можливо
вас цікавить питання або ви виявили
бажання підключити в закладі освіти
система Google Work Space fergocation і
саме На цьому ресурсі ви маєте чотири
прості кроки які розповідають дії які
варто виконати для того щоб отримати
безкоштовно для закладу освіти таку
систему яка дійсно дозволить розгорнути
інформаційно-освітнє середовище із
надзвичайно високим рівнем безпеки та
взаємодії а другим набором набором
рекомендацій і також знаходиться на цій
сторінці є перелік кроків як отримати
ноутбуки Chromebook для мого закладу
освіти і ця інструкція для вас також
наявна третій блок контенту в цьому
центральному ресурсі має назву для
батьків як тільки ви здійсните перехід
до нього то зможете опрацювати і
посібники і розглянути як працює
спеціально цифровий застосунок Family
ling для того щоб допомогти дітям в
цифровому світі і багато дидактичних
роздаткових матеріалів ресурсів які
можна використати для того щоб допомогти
нашим дітям бути безпечними в
онлайн-просторі цей ресурс є офіційним і
центральним проте я хочу сьогодні ще й
представити іншу ініціативу яка є
унікальною для України це організація
дистанційного навчання за річною
програмою Вона має назву цифрові
інструменти Google для освіти це
ініціатива спільне Міністерства освіти і
науки України за підтримки Google
Україна задля розширення можливостей
використання цифрових інструментів
навчання є повністю безоплатним ви
можете зареєструватись на будь-який
місяць адже щомісяця проводиться
ідентична сесія курс повторюється 12
разів щоб надати можливість кожному
представнику освітньої галузі отримати
такі навички і бути успішним
користувачем різних пристроїв Як ви
бачите є додаткові ініціативи для тих
закладів освіти працівники яких у
відсотковому співвідношенні 50 і більше
пройдуть навчання за базовим рівнем
можна отримати унікальний Статус який
підтримує Google України і з назвою
Google froducation Тобто учасник
програми і на сайті який ви наразі
бачите на екрані представлена основна
інформація традиційно я виводжу засобами
веб-переглядача Google Chrome qr-код для
того щоб ви тут і зараз могли
відсканувати і вже почати знайомитись із
таким сайтом в подальшому у нас
спеціальній сторінці презентуємо і
додаткові відомості Отже якщо ви
зацікавили реєстрація і ви бажаєте взяти
участь нагадує що програма річна можна
розподілити учасників педагогічного
колективу невеличкими групами для того
щоб пройти частину навчання наприклад у
вересні чи жовтні А де хтось працівників
може здійснити навчання у травні чи
червні і найважливішим є те що і таке
навчання є диференційованим Ми
пропонуємо вам три різні рівні базовий
рівень Є унікальним як відповідь на
виклики які отримала наша країна в
умовах війни це навчання використовувати
і органі використовувати освітній процес
з мобільним пристроєм за підсумками
такого навчання можна отримати
сертифікат на 30 годин а середній і
поглиблений рівень безпосередньо
дозволять познайомитись освітянам і з
тим як ефективно використовувати
веб-переглядач для будь-якої операційної
системи комп'ютера а поглиблений рівень
для тих кому пощастить отримати пристрої
хромбук або
застосувати систему хром ос флекс яка
дозволяє відновити життя будь-яких
старих комп'ютерів можна здійснити такі
оновлення безкоштовно тут і зараз хотіла
привернути вашу увагу до того що кожен
рівень Є актуальним забезпечується
сертифікатами і для різних пристроїв є
можливість працювати із вивченням
цифрових навичок у практику
орієнтованому підході тобто мінімум
теорії і максимальні практичні ситуації
реалізації і навички які ви отримаєте
разом із командою тренерів а найближчим
часом Ми запрошуємо всіх глядачів
відвідати вебінари які відбудуться уже
22 і 23 серпня окремо для педагогічних
працівників і для керівників закладів
освіти адже програма тільки стартує
протягом року передбачені різні
активності ініціативи і для педагогічних
працівників ми презентуємо особливості
організації освітнього процесу з
використанням хромбук а також як оновити
пристрої хром осфлекс щоб вони працювали
швидше і забезпечували професійну
діяльність а для керівників закладів
освіти особливості використання цих
пристроїв або операційної системи для
організації освітнього процесу а також
надважливі відповіді на запитання як
організувати наступний експериментально
або управлінську діяльність на базі
рішення
а також вони презентована процедура як
подати заявку для того щоб закладу
отримати такий статус і ми не просто
оголошуємо про цей вебінар А я б хотіла
зробити ось такий акцент із
переключенням камер що я хочу у прямому
ефірі оголосити ще одну дуже класну
ініціативу а саме що для тих закладів
освіти які до жовтня місяця встигнуть
отримати статус учасник програми Google
переджеcation буде використано унікальна
можливість отримати хромбук у подарунок
адже у жовтні а буде проведена
міжнародна конференція під час якої буде
представлений довід організації навчання
випускників які уже отримали результати
і застосували в
своїй професійній діяльності Отже
програма цифрові інструменти Google для
освіти організовується протягом цілого
року ми Закликаємо реєструватися
слідкувати за новинами на сайті ви
бачите в усіх джерелах і ресурсах і
обов'язково маю презентувати пристрій
хромбук Чим же ж він є таким важливим в
освітній діяльності тому що він легкий
він безпечний він простий і дійсно
організація професійної діяльності
освітнього процесу за їх допомогою буде
надзвичайно ефективне адже все
надзвичайно просто операційна система
Chrome яка є серцем кожному хромбу може
вам бути отримана або в цьому пристрої
або через оновлення операційної системи
Chrome ос адже так ми перевірили цей
пристрій надзвичайно швидко запускається
він миттєво вирішує всі ваші задачі і
безпека а понад усе знаходиться у
пріоритеті при роботі із такими засобами
а наприкінці нашої програми такого
огляду мого виступу Я б хотіла ще
розповісти і презентувати інші а
можливості як у нас блок третій у
програмі має назву цифрова
компетентність освітян і сьогодні Ми
запрошуємо вас до взаємодії через
відповіді у Google формі і ці підсумки
представимо трошки пізніше а маю я маю
честь наразі представити і запросити до
слова пані Зою Литвин яка для нас
презентує спеціальні курси нової
української школи і як їх можна отримати
реалізувати В своїй діяльності
[музика]
рушійна сила освіти - це вчителі цим
курсом Ми допомагаємо їм посилити свої
компетенції і тим самим впровадити
реформу нової української школи
це можливість звірити уявлення про нову
українську школу та побудувати
ефективний освітній процес
[музика]
ми дібрали найкращі підходи та
інструменти які зроблять впровадження
реформи дійсно ефективним а навчальний
процес цікавим і захоплюючим
нова українська школа - це місце де всі
залучені до освітнього процесу зростають
вчаться почуваються безпечно та
піклуються одне про одного
[оплески]
[музика]
вітання колеги ще раз рада всіх бачити І
знаєте продовжуючи тему цифрової
трансформації цифрових навичок
українського вчительства скажу що
завдяки ковід тепер вже можемо казати
завдяки враховуючи інші обставини
цифрові навички освітян дуже швидко
підвищились і Напевно це одна з причин
чому так швидко вдалося нам поновити
навчальний процес спочатку війни І от
наступним викликом звичайно стоїть як ми
можемо продовжити
наступальність реформи нова українська
школа бо це важливо реформа нова
українська школа - це най підтримуваніша
суспільством реформа рейтинги і
підтримки 76% середнього якщо ми
говоримо про батьків учнів пілотних
класів було окреме дослідження і на 81%
вони в захваті від реформи тому що вони
бачать що діти хочуть іти до школи що у
дітей розвивається дослідницькі
компетенції розвивається
важливі навички 21 століття а отже наша
з вами задача продовжувати цю реформу
попри війну особливо враховуючи той факт
що зараз велика кількість наших
українських дітей перебуває за кордоном
в тих освітніх системах де
стандарти нуш вже впроваджені ефективно
працюють тож ми маємо бути готові
зустрічати їх в своїх класах 17-го року
наша команда допомагала зі стартом
реформи нуш ми робили перший онлайн-курс
для вчителів початкової школи ми
тренували тренерів які далі вже в полях
наживо тренували вчителів і власне цього
року ми так само продовжуємо цю роботу
але вже для середньої школи ну і тут
Якщо можна я поділюся екраном і розкажу
вам про ті курси з якими ми будемо
працювати
перший курс про який хочу розказати це
саме курс нуш базова середня освіта як
сказала розрахована на вчителів
середньої школи але я думаю що і решті
освітян це буде цікавий і потрібний курс
він складається з наступних тем Це новий
зміст освіти про цінність взагалі
сутність реформи нова українська школа
наступний важливий блок - це про дітей
нуш Хто вони Чому вони інші Ну а власне
ті вчителі які працюють наживо з ними в
школі Вже бачать що це зовсім інші діти
Вони набагато більш вільні і нам
потрібно буде адаптуватися до їхніх
потреб до їхнього стилю навчання третій
блок - це Сучасні підходи в роботи з
учнівством І власне це і будуть такі
практичні інструменти методи і лайфхаки
від найкращих практиків з усієї України
дуже важливий блок оцінювання він буде
мати фокус на формувальному оцінюванні
на питання рубрик на тих термінах які ми
як правило як правило з вимовами
Ну і останній важливий блок він буде
галузевий він буде містити в собі Ті
такі лайфхаки і методи в залежності від
галузі Чи це
природничі науки Чи це
читання література або ж це математика
тобто кожен вчитель-предметник знайде
для себе в цьому модулі щось своє що він
одразу може брати і впроваджувати на
своїх уроках
курс складається з 22 уроків об'єднаних
в ці модулі до нього Ми залучили 25
дивовижних експертів практиків з реформи
нуш курс є безкоштовний і по його
проходженню проходження тестів вчитель
зможе отримати
сертифікат на 30 годин з підвищення
кваліфікації Ну і курс створено власне
за підтримки фонду дитячого фонду ООН
юнісеф і звичайно ж Міністерство освіти
і науки України
дуже раді що він з'явився тому що нуш
треба впроваджувати і додам ще від себе
курс знаходиться на Новій платформі яку
ми власне запустили позавчора вона
зветься о університет і її створена за
підтримки і посольства Сполучених Штатів
Америки в Україні ну ж це перший курс
який на ній з'являється а наступним буде
ще це дуже важливий курс який зветься Я
поруч це курс спрямований на
психологічну підтримку і такі ментальний
добробут учнів Ну і одразу скажу що й
самих вчителів Адже для того щоб ми
якісно змогли підтримати наших учнів в
період війни ми маємо прокачати свої
психологічно педагогічні компетенції
розуміти себе і знати як підтримувати
учнів Цей курс буде давати відповіді на
питання як ідентифікувати стан учня і
підтримувати його під час навчання і в
позаурочний час ну
і так як я вже сказала на підтримку себе
і навіть колег вчителів
це те на чому працюємо
створено З любов'ю для українських
освітян
Так
дякую за увагу продовжуємо далі
та І власне Я хочу передати слово Оксані
Федоренко з команди уєро тому що таких
курсів які можуть озброїти вчителів до
початку нового року в Нових умовах дуже
багато що не може не радувати пані
Оксано Вітаю передаю вам слово
дякую пані Зоя Доброго дня усім маю за
честь сьогодні представляти українські
інститут розвитку освіти в цій локації і
дійсно в продовження будемо говорити про
курс для педагогів Ми думали що пандемія
ковід викликала найбільший Збільш в
системі освіти за останні десятиліття
Але ми всі побачили як ми помилялися
війна в Україні привнесла і продовжує
приносити нові виклики і тому сьогодні
як ніколи попри все важливо підтримувати
освітній процес і забезпечувати
професійний розвиток педагогів
нашою ціллю є сучасний і доступний в
Україні та межами змісту освіти тому що
ми вже чули і знаємо що і українські
педагоги і українські діти перебувають
сьогодні в тому числі за межами України
тобто щоб учні могли максимально
ефективно у зручний час та у зручному
місці навчатися а вчителі навчати їх
допомогти адаптуватися вчителям і учням
та якісно перелаштувати освітню
діяльність покликана всеукраїнська школа
онлайн або весело як ми звикли її
називати Про неї вже сьогодні багато
говорили і в тому справді є великий сенс
але ми пішли далі аби підтримати
вчителів у розвитку цифрових
компетентностей та показати їм на
практиці усі Вигоди і можливості
всеукраїнської школи онлайн Ми створили
курс всеукраїнська школа онлайн для
реалізації дистанційного та чи змішаного
навчання
розробниками курсу є державна установа
Український інститут розвитку освіти за
підтримки дитячого фонду ООН юнісеф в
Україні
цільова група цього курсу вчителі 5-11
класів загальної середньої освіти
актуальність розроблення в необхідності
підготовки вчителів до роботи в умовах
посилення ролі цифрових технологій
організація освітнього процесу та
активного використання технології
дистанційного навчання ну в тому числі і
лише
трішки про курс курс складається із 14
навчальних відео які розкривають
компетентнісний підхід у новій
українській школі та його реалізацію в
умовах дистанційного чи то змішаного
навчання
демонструють роль вчителя у цифровому
суспільстві та використання цифрових
технологій і технології дистанційного
навчання в освітньому процесі
акцентують увагу на оцінювання
результатів навчання учнів в умовах
цифрового освітнього середовища і
підсвічують як цифрові технології
використовую для розбудови інклюзивного
освітнього середовища
складається не тільки з відео є теорія є
різноманітні завдання для самоперевірки
та приклади з практики Ну і червоною
ниткою через Олесь курси для вчителів
проходить всеукраїнська школа онлайн для
нас було дуже важливо щоб матеріали вшау
не сприймалися як тимчасово рішення для
умов коли очний формат недоступний адже
цей онлайн-ресурс та інші онлайн-ресурси
Вони мають дуже великий потенціал і якщо
їх вдало використати то вони якісно
слугуватиму для організації
дистанційного чи то змішаного навчання
для забезпечення індивідуальної
освітньої траєкторії учнів тож одне з
головних завдань нашого онлайн-курсу для
вчителів це показати як використовувати
онлайн-ресурси зокрема і виши для
організації освітнього навчального
процесу
ми переконані що онлайн-курси є вдалими
рішеннями щоб сьогодні попри все
підтримувати ось таку екосистему
цифрової освіти та сприяти професійному
розвитку педагогічних працівників
ми створили Цей курс у партнерстві з
юнісеф щоб підсвітити потенціал цифрових
рішень для сучасного і для майбутнього
курс безкоштовний і
сподіваюся що нам не завадить з вересня
місяця вже повністю запустити його і він
буде доступний педагогам Отож вже з
вересня чекайте на наш курс
дякую
Вам уже знайомий цей символ це
національна платформа можливостей
професійного розвитку педагогічних
працівників adway А це сайт платформи
adway.in.ua
нею можуть скористатися педагогічні
працівники працівниці
заклади освіти установи центри
професійного розвитку
суб'єкти підвищення кваліфікації і Дехто
з колег уже тут знайомтеся ось пані
Світлана вона вже пропонує навіть два і
програми підвищення кваліфікації для
мене та платформа вона як соціальна
мережа коли учасники можуть долучатися
можуть спілкуватися можуть шукати для
себе освітні можливості брати в них
участь а рекомендувати своїм друзям і
такий майданчик для тих хто хоче
отримати якісну послугу і тих хто може
надати освітню можливість а пані Людмила
представляє заклад освіти вона
директорка школи
активація кабінету на платформі
підвищення кваліфікації тих людей дає
нас можливості адміністрація також може
за допомогою цієї платформи отримати
відомості про те хто над чим працює і
які знання можна отримати а кожна
педагог має можливість або зростати або
самому надати послуги підвищення
кваліфікації через різноманітність
доєднуйтеся аби професійно зростати
разом з нами
а Ми продовжуємо роботи тематичного
блоку цифрова компетентність освітян і я
хочу запросити до слова менеджерку
проєкту дія цифрова освіта пані Руслану
коринчук прошу про Доброго дня Доброго
дня колеги Дякую Антоніна Отож сьогодні
трошечки поширюю інформацію про те якій
є результати і в успішні кейси по
впровадженню додаткових продуктів які
будуть корисні для вчительської
спільноти від проекту дія цифрова освіта
Отож я надіюся що ви всі з ним знайомі
це власне велика платформа на якій є
понад уже 80 освітніх курсів різної
спрямованості різного віку різних
вікових категорій і відповідно різних
спеціальностей Але якщо говорити про
напрямок який буде корисний і які
продукти будуть корисними саме для
вчителів то ось наступне власне перший
продукт рамка Я теж щиро надіюся завжди
з нею знайомі їй уже трошки більше ніж
півтора роки саме український адаптації
Отож вона налічує власне 5 сфер
компетентностей 22 компоненти цифрової
грамотності і з ними всіма ви більш
детальніше можете зіткнутися коли будете
проходити національний тест на цифрову
грамотність - це програм які
орієнтований в тому числі і на вчителів
сам по собі тест має насправді
декілька теж категорій
їх наразі є чотири Тобто це програма для
громадян України всіх в цілому для
педагогічних працівників про які ми
говоримо для медичних працівників та для
держслужбовців що ж є для вчителів як ви
розумієте цей тест хто його проходив це
там від півгодини до години часу
опитування про те що ви розумієте під
теми чи іншими категоріями якби діяли
тих чи інших ситуаціях та Як ви
вирішували ті чи інші проблеми тобто
дуже наживний дуже життєвий та
результативний з приводу
результатів того скільки з вас колеги це
прийшли то понад 210 тисяч осіб почали
проходити тестування трішки звичайно
менша кількість пройшла до кінця але це
все одно дуже позитивний результат це
більше понад 75%. якщо розбиратися по
результатах хто теж як на мене
результати радують Чому Тому що в кожній
категорії як ми можемо побачити
наприклад ось учитель в цифровому
суспільстві основна маса людей які
склали його на категорію B2 це вище
середнього рівня Це аж 42%
схожі відсотки є і по інших категоріях і
по професійному розвитку і
використання та аналізу цифрових
ресурсів і по навчанню та оцінювання
учнів і так само по розвитку цифрових
компетентностей саме для учнів
Відповідно
ми ще й досі приймаємо пропозиції по
тому як питання можна змінити які можна
актуалізувати і відповідно прошу Якщо у
вас є таке пропозиції є звертайтеся
надсилайте свою інформацію з радістю їх
додамо оновимо і проходити його буде
дійсно легше швидше і ще простіше тепер
з приводу додаткових
власне освітніх серіалів і курсів які ми
і славиться дія цифрова освіта це три
серіали які можуть бути для вас
помічними це цифрові навички для
вчителів
Як ви бачите те що непопулярний в плані
того що за останні рік його пройшла дуже
багато людей так само це оглядовий
серіал який був на піку популярності під
час карантину карантину оглядовий серіал
для вчителів онлайн-сервіси там серіал
про інтерактивне навчання інструменти і
технології для цікавих уроків кожен із
цих серіалів дійсно знайшов відгук у
багатьох із вас відразу відповідає на
запитання що їх теж можна
використовувати для підвищення
кваліфікації і теж зараховувати як собі
додаткове навчання в поза давайте
називати позаурочний час тому
коротке рев'ю по платформі аби не
затримувати колег надалі
просто хочу сказати що якщо у вас є
пропозиції по серіалах надсилайте якщо я
пропозиції по цифрограмах так само
присилайте тому що можемо вносити
додаткові оновлення запитання які будуть
для вас найбільш релевантні і приємні
наразі дякую за увагу якщо буде
запитання пишіть дякую
дякую пані Русланом і ми маємо підбити
невеличкі проміжні підсумки роботи
третього тематичного блоку цифрова
компетентність освіти наразі спікери
представили величезний перелік ресурсів
програм ініціатив для того щоб
передати або акцентувати увагу про те що
з ними можна працювати І використовувати
вже зараз просто маючи знання про те що
все це запроваджено і започатковано і
наразі ми підіб’ємо підсумки у
нестандартному варіанті роботи і форми
організації я включила спеціально наш
сайт де на лівій бічній навігаційній
панелі ви бачите розділ який має назву
матеріал Нагадую що цей сайт ви можете
відкрити з будь-якого пристрою сторінка
із якою щойно відкрила має вбудований
qr-код А який також можете зупинити
відсканувати і Саме цей ресурс за
підсумками роботи нашої локації буде
оздобленим всіма активними покликаннями
переходами презентаціями описами тих
представлень які сьогодні відбулися у
прямому ефірі блок один про wi-fi
укриття як подати заявку будь ласка для
вас форма цифровий контент і різні
ресурси відкривайте безпосередньо звідси
блок третій ті представлені ресурси будь
ласка Ви також можете для себе уже
використовувати І передавати іншим коли
я озвучила термін передавати хотілося б
запросити вас до активної взаємодії якщо
ви продовжите давати відповіді на
актуальні запитання прямого ефіру будь
ласка це теж важливий варіант про те
наша робота скоро до біжить кінця і за
підсум пропонуємо вам отримати
застосувавши власні цифрові навички
бейдж у електронному вигляді бейдж
учасника що для цього треба зробити будь
ласка
активуйте кнопку на сайті відповідно
нашого заходу де ви бачите напис
отримати і зробіть це Будь ласка за
допомогою комп'ютера система запропонує
Вам зробити і отримати копію цього файла
Куди Вам потрібно буде лише додати ваше
власне фото або логотип організації для
того щоб поділитися в офіційних ресурсів
соціальних мережах і залучити відповідно
разом
поділитися і використати рішення для
того щоб освіта стала цифровою і ми
змогли її повністю відбудувати Ваші дії
простими це полотно Google Jambo Ліворуч
є панель інструментів де вам потрібно
лише активувати додати зображення
вибрати на вашому пристрої як я і
зазначала або ваше фото або
фотоорганізації адже це можуть бути
рекомендації від управління освіти
Департаменту тощо я особи тому Я додаю
фотографії і для того щоб цей Бей
отримати у вигляді файлу крайня дія яку
треба виконати це праворуч його Різ
знайти і натиснути кнопку три
вертикальні крапки а далі зберегти фрейм
як зображення в підсумку на вашому
пристрої буде графічний файл яким можна
ділитися або людина або організація і
заклик який ми сьогодні озвучуємо до вас
шановні глядачі що Не будьте байдужими
якщо ви знаєте що такі ресурси
ініціативи
програми існують Та будь ласка і
поділіться з іншими для того щоб ми
використовували їх постійно і ефективно
А ми продовжу роботу нашої локації і на
часі тематичний блок номер чотири який
має назву цифрові процеси і я хочу
запросити до слова пані Наталю яка є
експертом аналітиком команди підтримки
реформ Міністерства освіти і науки
України пані Наталю прошу
мікрофон Доброго дня дякую пані Антоніна
Я дуже рада бути модератором одне із
найцікавіших платформ одної найцікавіших
частин тому що вона присвячена
безпосередньо практичній частині і
досвіду наших директорів які є
амбасадорами цифровізації і
дебюракретизації електронного
документообігу тому я до студії запрошую
пані Юлію
пані Андрія па- пане Андрія і Пані лілію
ви знаєте що робота по цифровізації
процесів йде вже декілька років і є над
нею працює багато людей які є практиками
які є державними службовцями посадовими
особами місцевого самоврядування але
хочу сказати що
була пророблена дуже багато роботи як
нормативної так як закон про айкоми про
реєстри в освіті такий як положення про
Еко але була і технічна частина
здійснена дуже велика
розроблена і запроваджена іком державний
модуль державного класного журналу який
дає змогу всім хто не має можливості
застосовувати приватні сервіси міг би
скористатися державним електронним
класним журналом крім того наразі якому
розвивається і
запроваджено ще один модуль який
називається електронне діло суспільство
яке містить більше журналів таких як
реєстрація свідоцтв досягнення таких як
реєстрація
інструктажів і так далі Слідкуйте за
оновленнями на сайті і ви побачите більш
детальнішу інформацію Наразі я хочу вас
познайомити ближче з нашою командою пані
Юлія будь ласка представтеся вітаю я
Юлія Степанюк директорка опорного ліцею
села зимне що на Волині ми не ведемо
паперових журналів у своїй школі а вже
два роки користуємось виключно
електронними класними журналами Дякую
Пане Андрію
Добрий день Андрій Малахов директор
Миколаївської загальноосвітньої школи
№57 імені Тараса Григоровича Шевченка
Наша команда займається розбудовою
діджиталізації закладу яка дасть
можливість впровадити ефективну модель
управління якістю надання освітніх
послуг електронними журналами Та
щоденниками ми користуємося з 2011 року
з 2013 року ми розвиваємо систему
системну роботу щодо цифрової
компетентності вчителів і 2017 року
затвердили програму діджиталізації
закладу яка дає побудувати єдиний
інформаційний простір в якому
задіяні на інформаційному рівні і
пов'язані між собою всі учасники
освітнього процесу а саме учні батьки
вчителі та адміністрації дякую дякую
пані Лілія
будь ласка мікрофончик
поки пані Лілія готується і в неї має
трошки технічних проблем Я хочу перейти
до такого інтерв'ю там де ми можемо
поставити питання нашим агентам змін які
розкажуть про свій практичний досвід
тому питання до Опана Андрія будь ласка
поділіться досвідом Як ви пройшли цей
шлях і запроваджували електронний
документообіг прошу Дякую за запитання Я
хотів би зараз
показати як ми це робили
[музика]
Так в нас Наскільки я розумію видно
екран так Ні я не бачу
спробуйте будь ласка ще раз
ЗАО бачимо
бачимо екранчик можете відкрити
презентацію більше щоб ми його її могли
[музика]
зараз видно Так дякую
значить інформаційна система закладу
вона
та освітнього процесу вона створена у
нас на платформі Google Space ukration
де ми використовували Google інструменти
та додатки ця система складається з
трьох таких підсистем це навчального
управліньська та представницька
управлінська Складається також іще з
таких підсистем як комунікаційна
аналітична та документообіг і саме про
документообіг я хотів би і розповісти
своєму виступі
документообіг він передбачає як вхід на
вихідна документація це також
журнали реєстрації вхідної документації
це електронні щоденники але я хотів би
почати з того як ми це все
запроваджували і надо в комплектації у
нас находить до школи через
електронно-поштову скриньку та
автоматично переадресовується на адресу
шкільного акаунта користувача який
визначений як приймальна далі з поштової
зрозуміти шкільного Google акаунту є
можливість одразу зберігати документацію
на відповідному Google диску і в папці
вхідні документи реєстрацію східної
документації можна здійснювати або через
форму Google форму ви бачите Ось вона
тут показана або безпосередньо через
Google таблицю яка називається журнал
реєстрації вхідна документація в чому
тут особливість при реєстрації вхідної
документації вказ за номер за порядком
вхідного документу назва документу адрес
Ну і так далі Тобто всі реквізити в
таблиці автоматизована встановлення
індексу справи відповідно до розробленої
номенклатури справ і спочатку З
випадаючого списку потрібно обрати
розділ а потім уже відповідно до
обраного розділу В наступній комісії
з'являється список індексів справ що
значно полегшує роботу я як директор
розглядаючи цей прикріплений вхідний до
документ накладаю туди резолюцію
визначає особу яка буде працювати з
даним документом та терміни цього
виконання відповідно до того що
передбачає певний документ адміністратор
переходить до роботи з внутрішніми
документами це може бути накази
розпорядження або до формування певного
вихідного документу і далі вже
адміністратор опрацювавши цю
документацію він створює проект і
прикріплює до його також до електронної
Google таблиці журнал реєстрації
вихідної уже документації він вказує цей
таблиці всі реквізити вихідного
документу і за необхідності Я також можу
ще відредагувати прикріплений вихідний
документ а після цього вже секретар
реєструє його вказує номер та вихідний
дату вихідний номер та відправляє
електронною поштою або кур'єром адресату
Це ось показана схема як це саме
відбувається для роботи з внутрішньою
документацією Я маю на увазі на указ
накази ми створили накази Google таблицю
накази з основної діяльності журнал
реєстрації основою якого є попередня
циклограма наказі ось видно тут якщо
підготовлений уже проект наказу і він
погоджений то там у нас висвітлюється
зеленим кольором якщо ще потрібно
доопрацювання то там уже написано до
опрацювання він червоним кольором після
того як документ уже доопрацьований Він
отримує статус погоджено і секретар
надає йому номер роздруковує і доводить
до відома співробітників крім того
адміністрації і секретар повинні
постійно мати доступ до цілої групи
документів які постійно оновлюються і
щоб кожного разу не додавати цей доступ
до окремого документу було створено
такий підрозділ який називається
адміністрація це на спільному Google
дискі де дає право редагувати цій групі
ну всі ті зміни які необхідно внести
кожним учасником групи Ну то есть видно
які тут знаходяться папки і для
організації швидкого доступу
представниками адміністрації до
електронних документів було створено
Google сайт
дітей документообіг головна сторінка
цього сайту вона вмістить вбудований
документ номенклатура справ Google
Календар тут є також щось кнопки вхід на
документація вихід на документація
журнал внутрішніх документів нормативна
база України і також 4 види наших
наказів накази з основної діяльності
накази з рук уроків накази з кадрових
питань та накази за адміністративного
господарства і діяльності це якщо
говорити коротенько ті які форми Ми
використовували для того щоб ну
створити даний електронний документообіг
дякую Скажіть Пане Андрію а як було
розцінили Що для вас було найбільшою
перепоною коли ви це запроваджували ну
от як щось одне можете ідентифікувати Да
я можу ідентифікувати перше - це та
нормативна база з якою потрібно було
ознайомитись бо що дає можливість ввести
документи виключно в незаконному вигляді
і дякуючи Міністерство освіти і науки
зараз уже Наскільки я розумію і ви
говорили на виході вже цей документ саме
про електронний документообіг який
значно спростити ці процедури тому що ми
повністю відмовились від паперових Носії
будь-яких
Добре дякую вам я бачу до нас
приєдналася пані Лілія будь ласка пані
Лілія тоді продовжимо будь ласка
представтеся і Якщо можете відповість
надайте відповідь на питання Я знаю що
просто у вас уже довгий час є
електронний журнал як він подала допоміг
подолати вам труднощі з якими стикнулися
учасники освітнього процесу під час
початку пандемії а потім війни
Доброго дня Лілія вавринів директорка
Тернопільської загальноосвітньої школи
№28 І ми теж мали таку радість цього
року абсолютно вже відмовитися від
паперових журналів і повністю перейшли
на електронні журнали та електронні
щоденники так пандемія і
воєнний стан те що зараз відбувається в
нашій країні це є виклики в тому числі
це особливі виклики і для освітян для
освітянської роботи і саме те що ми мали
таку практику і такий досвід Це дало нам
можливість в першу чергу
успішної комунікації між всіма
учасниками освітнього процесу тобто між
адміністрацією та вчителями між
вчителями та учнями між вчителями та
батьками незалежно від того де перебував
суб’єкт де перебувала людина і
незважаючи на якісь часові обмеження
Окрім цього цей зв'язок це комунікація
можлива за користування будь-якими
технічними засобами тобто ноутбуки
комп'ютери
смартфони планшети також це ми під час
воєнних дій зрозуміли що це дає
можливість нам згенерувати за допомогою
електронних журналів електронного
документообігу певні елементарні
документи які необхідні батькам та учням
Тобто ми можемо
в любому форматі класний керівник
згенерувати довідку про успішність
довідку про те що дитина навчається є
учнем нашого закладу
табель свідоцтва досягнень і зручному
форматі передати туди куди це не
необхідно Ну і крім того це дуже зручна
можливість моніторити освітній процес як
адміністрації в загальному освітній
процес освітнього закладу так і
моніторинг батьків
успішність і діяльність своєї дитини так
і вчитель-предметник свого предмету чи
класний керівник свого класу
дякую пані Лілія дивіться я хочу хотіла
вас запитати А чи стикалась ви з
проблемою цифрових компетентностей
вчителів батьків дітей і якщо стикалася
то як ви з цим боролися
чи стикалися з проблемою що у них
відсутня цифрова компетентність так
відсутня можливо недостатньо скажімо
недостатньо звичайно і буду сміливо
говорити що воно зустрічається як серед
вчителів так і серед батьків
як ми боролися якщо приходять батьки і
кажуть Ми не знаємо ми не вміємо Ми не
можемо ми знаходимо час знаходимо
можливість садимо маму біля себе і
допомагаємо їй зареєструватися увійти
показуємо наскільки це комфортний і
зручний інструмент ну а для вчителів це
регулярна
підтримка і адміністрації у вигляді
різноманітних курсів по підвищенню
кваліфікації і безпосередньо підтримка
для вчителів інформатики в першу чергу
де з любим запитанням вони можуть
звернутися і окрім того ми намагаємося
виховувати вчителя так щоб він не боявся
по допомогу звернутися до учня тому
ця проблема вона проблема часу і вона
механічна проблема вона вирішується Я
вам дуже дякую Що Ви не боїтеся таких
перешкод перепон Дякую вам пані Юлія
Розкажіть про свій шлях своє етапи Як ви
запроваджували електронний документообіг
шлях з впровадження електронних журналів
в складався з декількох етапів Спочатку
ми провели аналіз таке широке опитування
між всіма учасниками освітнього процесу
для того щоб дізнатися чи вчителі учні
та батьки готові до впровадження якихось
цифрових інструментів освітній процес і
рівень готовності був дуже високий
справді ми не очікували такого рівня
коли ми проаналізували всі анкети а
другим і напевно найважчим етапом Це був
етап вивчення нормативно-правової бази
щодо ведення саме електронних класних
журналів відмовившись від паперових це
було складно адже є багато законів
багато законодавчих актів А конкретики
такої чіткості так або паперовий або
електронний немає і ми знайшли Ми шукали
знайшли і далі на рівні до свого закладу
розробляли власні документи інструкцію
щодо ведення електронного класного
журналу положення наступним етапом було
затвердять затвердження цих документів і
п'ятим напевно таким найвагомішим і
найбільш трудомістким етапом був етап
навчання педагогів саме основ роботи з
електронними журналами з цим
функціоналом для того щоб педагогів
впевнено себе відчували і не могли
достойно виглядати саме в очах учнів і
звичайно постійно технічно та
консультативна підтримка усіх учасників
освітнього процесу щодо саме
впровадження таких цифрових рішень в
освітній процес дякую Скажіть будь ласка
а чи стикалися ви з опором від
педагогічного персоналу при
запровадженні електронного журналу Так
саме при прийнятті ось цих рішень тих
документів декілька Ну я не скажу що був
великий відсоток можливо відсотка два
від цього колективу сказали що вони не
хочуть бо це безглузда ну це безглуздо
ну як так не можна все одно треба писати
Ось і ці люди які були проти тоді
наприкінці першого семестру були
найбільш задоволені електронними
класними журналами тому боятися не варто
Супер дякую вам
Хотіла би додати те що
презентація пана Андрія Малахова буде
розміщена на сайті нашої панелі тому
якщо ви хочете більш детально
ознайомитися будь ласка завантажуєте її
сайту ви знаєте
наостанок Я хотіла би щоб ви можливо
поділилися своїми лайфхаками для
директорів які можливо тільки стоять на
початку запровадження електронного
документообігу і щоб ви їм порадили пані
Лілія
однозначно впроваджувати електронний
документообіг і саме починати потрібно з
електронного журналу електронного
щоденника як керівнику для адміністрації
це дасть можливість легко спілкуватися з
учнями з великою кількістю учнів в
ручному для вас місці вручному для вас
форматі окрім того хочу ще порадити таке
як індивідуальні батьківські збори тобто
формат старих пострадянських
класних зборів він вже відживає своє він
є неефективний і тому саме за допомогою
електронних журналів ми можемо
спілкуватися безпосередньо конкретно про
дитину про її здобутки про її освітню
траєкторію ну і ще такий лайфхак що
Спілкуючись з розробниками
цифрових інструментів вони зараз дуже
вболівають за споживача і вони дуже
гарно ідуть на контакт і якщо ви
задумуєте свої такі директорські капризи
то Вони намагаються їх впровадити взуття
Супер дякую зворотний зв'язок
індивідуальний підхід це дуже важливо
для всіх учасників освітнього процесу І
взагалі зі всіма з кимось комунікуємо
пані Юлія
багато директорів
ставляться до впровадження електронних
інструментів скептично тому що треба
навчити всій батьків учнів і вчителів
ними користуватись Повірте вчити
прийдеться лише вчителі бо на них ніде
найбільше відповідальність за заповнення
електронних класних журналів а наша
молодь Наші учні настільки прогресивними
з чим Тільки треба платформа додаток
логін і пароль і Діти дуже швидко тому
навчаються і навчають і потім
користуватись в електронним Кабінетом і
батьків Тому не варто боятися вчителі
потрібно навчити А учні вони допоможуть
потім усім нічого не боятися і навчання
продовжиття це наше все дякую Пане
Андрію я хотів би додати ще таке що
варто використовувати весь той ресурс
всю цифру який тільки є для того щоб
перевести повністю Всю школу будь-яку
систему на цифру чому ми коли перевели
внутрішню систему якості забезпечення
освіти ви знаєте хто вже пройшов аудит
яка це величезна кислота і зберігати це
постійно змінюючи кожного разу коли
відбувається те чи інша анкетування
досить важко в нас повністю ця система
вся вже перекладена на Google таблиці
Так же само ми переклали і
скажемо ті програми ті підбиток тих
компетентностей які є уже в 5 класі
нової української школи то що до
зустрічі важко запам'ятати тримати це
все в голові і звичайний журнал звісно
цього не дає можливості перевівши це на
цифру ми значно скоротили весь шлях і я
скажу Та палітра вчителів коли ми
починали ну правда ще це давно було
говорю у 2010-му і в 11-му вже перейшли
електронні журнали електронні щоденники
але
наймолодший Вчитель - це в нас був зразу
після під училища це було 19 років
найстарший був 75 років і всі однаково
навчилися і однако працюємо тому вперед
вперед тільки вперед щоб цифра нам
полегшала набагато нашу роботу і
скоротила наш час Дякую вам пан Андрію а
ви можете Я Хочу по-перше наголосити
тому що пан Андріє побудував взагалі
весь електронний документообіг на
безкоштовних ресурсах ви могли би
перерахувати їх для того щоб можливо
окреслити
ресурси як зрозуміло що ми
використовуємо платформу безкоштовно
Google Там ми використовуємо Google
таблиці Google форми Google класи
Google опитування для комунікації Звісно
що Google Календар ми не проводимо
жодних нарад все в нас онлайн
відбувається всі оголошення розклад
зарахування до школи
ну перехід з класу в класи будь-які
оголошення Я вже не говорю за
представницькі функції за аналітичні
функції Тобто всі діаграми графіки і так
далі І так далі перераховувати можна
досить багато але повністю
використовуємо всі безкоштовні платформи
і спілкуючись так само із розробниками і
з новими знаннями ми постійно
просимо внести ті чи інші корективи для
того це можна було запровадити це
стосувалося журналів індивідуального
навчання Коли ще не було Це стосувалося
цих
ще не було наприклад 3-4 класі Ми
просили розробників вони пішли на
зустріч і як правильно вже сказала пані
Лілія не боятися співпрацювати з
розробниками вони дуже швидко йдуть на
зустріч і враховують всі наші пропозиції
ми І саме головне
радує те що коли його готувалася ця
інструкція з електронного документообігу
Коли ті чи інші впроваджені вайком то
безпосередньо зверталися до нас як ну на
місцях до практики з Міністерства освіти
і завдяки цьому Ну бачили зсередини як
це все відбувається дякую дякую Ви
знаєте У нас є питання в чаті до наших
колег наших учасників перше ви бачите на
екрані пане Андрія чи можна з вами
зв'язатися
так без питань в презентації ви знайдете
яка буде висидіти там наша електронна
пошта там наш сайт там наш сайт сторінка
фейсбуку без питань звісно Да дякую
дякую є ще одне питання
Чи можете ви сказати якими саме
електронними ресурсами ви користуєтесь
пані Юлія
для введення електронний класний
журналів ми використовуємо платформу
нові знання ну а для дистанційного
навчання Ми не використовуємо функціонал
нових знань використовуємо Google
Супер дякую пані Лілія Спочатку це була
платформа School але останніми роками ми
вже користуємося єдиною школою Дякую ви
знаєте друзі Я вам дуже вдячна за вашу
роботу за те що Ви не боїтеся змін за те
що ви тримаєте оборону на освітньому
фронті Дуже дякую всім хто
не зміг долучитися до нашої дискусії але
вони так само багато роблять для
української освіти дякую вам і ми
завершили нашу панель пані антоніну
Дякую колеги і у підсумок Я б хотіла
зазначити що саме під час цієї
локації коли були представлені кейси від
директорів шкіл Ми отримали
найпотужніший зворотний зв'язок і Наразі
я б хотіла представити ще й ті відповіді
які ви надали на запитання форми щодо
того які ж електронні журнали та системи
управління використовують в закладах
освіти наші глядачі Ось так
представлена система із використанням у
нас
лідером Поки що є Google wart Space
fergication і далі атомс єдина школа
нові знання і ця статистика вона буде
продовжувати нами збиратися для того щоб
дослідити дійсно А яка ж ситуація в
наших закладах реально відбувається ми
маємо продовжити нашу роботу і в
четвертому блоці для нас також актуально
представити описи
практики рекомендацій і першої до слова
відповідно до нашої програми Я хочу
запросити пані Світлану Литвинову
переключаємось
Прошу пані Світлану
щиро дякую пані Антоніна Мені дуже
приємно що
сьогодні я беру участь у такій нараді і
я прошу Запустити мені презентацію так
Дякую
Шановні колеги Сьогодні я хочу з вами
підняти питання про перспективи
впровадження і цифрової трансформації в
закладах загальної середньої освіти
нашим інститутом було запропоновано така
модель як паралельне навчання тобто щоб
в кожній школі було учні класи і
дистанційні ви можете запитати чи готові
заклади освіти до такої трансформації
звичайно треба виконати кілька кроків
для її реалізації і на сьогоднішній день
піднімається питання про необхідність і
наявність цифрового паспорту і к
компетентності вчителя для чого це
потрібно перше про готовність вчителів
ми можемо підтвердити що більшість
вчителів України були готові до такої до
такого паралельного навчання тому що
протягом 8 років в Україні
впроваджувались два широкомасштабних
проекти пані Антоніна я про вас не буду
казати буду казати тільки про свої це
хмарні сервіси в освіті де було задіяно
понад 2000 учнів і понад стаж шкіл
України де були Розгорнуті хмарні
середовища тому ковід і воєнний стан на
них ніяк не повліяв а тільки
дав поштовх до посилення
хмарної взаємодії і другий - Це
технологія навчання учнів розумники де
було розроблено 63 електронних освітні
ресурси на кожний урок з математики з
української мови і під час ковід і
воєнного стану вчителів 3 кроки могли
організувати для початкової школи
дистаннь повного масштабно дистанційне
навчання це вибір ресурсу до уроку
завантаження через Zoom спілкування і в
віртуальному кабінеті формування інди
максимальна траєкторія розвитку учнів
які ж на сьогоднішній день портрет наших
учнів цифровий портрет ну Подивіться
будь ласка всі мають практично мобільні
телефони
80% мають комп'ютер причому
99% підключення до мережі Інтернет про
що це говорить що 15% залишається які
потребують
педагогічної уваги і скоріш за все
допомоги Міністерства освіти з
забезпеченням гаджетів про те що
сьогодні говорилося в першому блоці Наші
учні знаходяться в мережі Інтернет від
трьох годин до постійного перебування І
що приємно зазначити що 70% все-таки
займається навчанням тобто виконують
домашні завдання
цифровий портрет вчителя трошки інший на
сьогоднішній день педагогічна спільнота
розділилася на два таких потужних
цифрові
спільноти перша спільнота яка
використовує Сервіси Google про які
сьогодні масштабно говориться і ви
використовуєте Google клас Як ви бачите
42% серед двох тисяч опитаних і їх
портрет це використання Zoom Google
Class і Viber тобто така Тріада для
забезпечення дистанційного навчання і
друга частина - це які використовують
сервіси офіс 365 зокрема сервіс тімс і
йому на допомогу іде Viber для миттєвих
повідомлень загалом наші вчителі активно
використовують сервіси і ви бачите що
самими вчителями було зазначено 33
сервіси Які можна використати в
освітньому процесі
приємно що 80% закладів освіти
напрацювали єдину політику тобто учень
зна свій вхід для дистанційного навчання
які ми сервісами буде користуватися під
час уроків але все-таки 10% це ті
вчителі які нам зазначили Що школа не
приділяє цьому уваги
більшість вчителів вдалося забезпечити
дистанційне навчання Зверніть увагу що
так відповіло 57 відсотків і Скоріш так
41 тобто протягом воєнного стану це
квітень місяць всі вчителі забезпечили
дистанційне навчання учнів навіть тих
які були евакуйовані а з території з
різних територій чи потрібно нашим
вчителям підвищувати свою кваліфікацію
от зверніть увагу і те що сьогодні
говорилося в першому другому блоках щодо
розвитку компетентності вчителів 48%
вчителів будуть навчатися дистанційно
якраз такі дистанційні курси - це є
тренд XXI століття і тренд періоду ковід
дерева єнний стан причому 48% також
зазначили що вони хочуть постійно
підвищувати свої кваліфікацію і
опановувати різні серві для того щоб
бути в тренді але викликає також
занепокоєння що головним інструментом
під час дистанційного навчання
зокрема в період воєнного стану став PDF
версія підручника зверніть увагу це
понад
90%. тобто для того щоб забезпечити
освітній процес нашим вчителям не
вистачило цифрових електронних ресурсів
і головна проблема залишилась інтернет
причому його якість тільки 12 зазначили
що у них є проблеми зворотнім зв'язком з
учнями на чому ми хочемо наголосити
приємно що Мої колеги які тільки що
виступали говорили про впровадження
електронного журналу ми вважаємо що на
сьогоднішній день це є найголовнішим
елементом в управлінні під час
дистанційного навчання тому що учні
вчителі директори шкіл розпорошені як по
всій Україні так і за кордоном Але є
такі нюанси як
хмарний варіант цих журналів оскільки
треба забезпечити доступ з мобільного з
планшета з ноутбука незалежно від того
де перебуває Ця особа яка має вносити
даних це журнал а також посилити
науково-методичну роботу закладів освіти
існує електронна бібліотека національна
академії педагогічних наук де
зберігаються понад 38 тисяч методичних
розробок працівниками Національної
академії другим аспектом Ми хочемо
сказати що вимоги до цих підручників
мають на сьогоднішній день бути іншими
Вони мають бути насичені маркерами
qr-кодами для того щоб бути учень міг
відтворити відео аудіо доповнену
реальність тест або інші якісь
зображення для чого це потрібно якщо ми
говоримо про навчання в
бомбосховищах якщо ми говоримо про
навчання домашні то є певні аспекти в
освітньому процесі за допомогою яких
можуть учні посилити зміст цього
підручника і розглянути як комп'ютерні
моделі так і доповнену реальність
Причому я демонструю вже зроблений
підручник освітні агенції міста Києва з
фізики сьомий восьмий
клас з доповненою реальністю і ви бачите
що автори цих підручників різні і їх
Можна реалізувати і відтворити доповнену
реальність учнів в будь який момент
другий аспект - це стосується
предметів природничого циклу ми знаємо
що існує контент такий як Фет такий як
Ед про різні сайти з конструкторами
проте на сьогоднішній день нас є
проблема І ми маємо формувати учителів
компетентності з аналізу цих сервісів і
ресурсів як педагогічного а не
технологічного інструментарію то есть
вони мають знати в якій момент
використати цей ресурс як його
використати Як оцінити діяльність учнів
з цим ресурсом і так далі тобто ця
проблема залишається на сьогоднішній
день відкритою причому Ми отримали лист
від закладів вищої освіти вони просять
нас також надати їм допомогу у
формуванні таких компетентностей і
останнє це індивідуальний підхід до
кожної дитини Тобто діти які постраждали
в період воєнного стану мають різні
компетентності відповідно навчання в
цьому навчальному році і треба зробити
індивідуальні розробити індивідуальні
навчальні програми дати можливість учням
опановувати зміст в індивідуальному
темпі тобто якщо він історію може
опанувати свої прогалини закрите за
місяць тому може математику для
математики
потрібно 2 Може на цьому етапі треба
розпочинати нам роботу саме з системами
штучного інтелекту і також хочу сказати
що
найефективніші результати впровадження
цифрових технологій на сьогоднішній день
здійснюється в межах проектів і ми
пропонуємо Міністерство освіти а також
розробникам
компанії Microsoft кампанії Google
започаткувати нові проекти з
удосконалення змісту освіти тобто
напрацювання таких
новітніх напрямів які на сьогоднішній
день Як ви бачите спрацювали на позитив
два проекти які забезпечили дистанційну
і неперервне навчання саме закладах
загальної середньої освіти Я запрошую
заклади освіти також приєднуватися до
наших проектів і всім бажаю плідної
співпраці Перемога на порозі Дякую за
увагу
дякую пані Світлано а Ми продовжуємо
нашу роботу і до слова Я запрошую пана
Олександра
прошу
Доброго дня колеги
Підкажіть будь ласка чи бачите мій екран
ще ні там треба увімкнути
чи бачите зараз
так усе добре
коли я радий вітати вас Я представляю
Microsoft компанію а саме напрямок
освіти в Україні хотів би протягом
виділеного часу
розповісти про такі ключові напрямки
нашої роботи в освіті як ми підтримуємо
власне всіх освітян в цей досить
інтенсивний тяжкий час в Україні
розпочати Я хотів би з
напрямків це перш за все ми фокусуємося
на роботі з міністерством освіти і науки
України Ми також приділяємо увагу
середньої освіти професійній освіті
вищої освіти і долучаємо до нашої роботи
також інших партнерів і загалом такий
внесок Microsoft від інших партнерів які
ми змогли долучити до підтримки освіти
складає зараз вже більше 100 мільйонів
доларів в Україні це на період від
власного початку військових дій іду
тепер про що саме
говоримо коли говоримо 100 мільйонів
доларів для освіти в Україні перш за все
це підтримка цифровізації освіти на всіх
рівнях від навчальних закладів до
державного рівня ми надаємо експертну
підтримку збудови архітектури цифрової
освіти озвуючись на хмарних та гібридних
рішеннях Ми також проводимо серії
навчань з підвищення цифрової
компетентності освітян і проводимо їх
хтось регулярно найближчий вже буквально
в понеділок 22 серпня так званий
it-будкемп інформацію ви отримуєте також
окремо
долучатися будь ласка До цього заходу
тому що він буде корисним всім тим
іт-спеціалістам які працюють цифровою
освітою в себе на місцях для всіх
освітян Також ми також підтримуємо
реінженірних систем керування освітнім
процесом маємо на увазі адміністративні
та навчальні
it-ресурси
це такий термінологія дещо англійський
Але я думаю що ви певні виріз знаєте про
що йде мова ми надаємо безкоштовні
освітні ліцензії це м365 це так званий
Word Excel PowerPoint on Note Та
звичайно ж Microsoft teams який широко
використовується в освіті і надає за
допомогою додаткових пагінів
широченні можливості освітньому процесі
Також ми надаємо ліцензії
Anger це хмарні ресурси для яких
зазвичай використовуються для викапу
інформації та віртуальних машин
віртуальних мереж також для штучного
інтелекту тобто все що весь цей світ
який ми зазвичай звикли бачити наприклад
там за допомогою кабелів так комп'ютерів
Це все можна перенести в хмару і і
забезпечити як безпеку інформації так І
власне безперебі тобто до ресурсів
звісно заключення до інтернету
Також ми надаємо ліцензії dynamics це
вже рішення для керування
адміністративними ресурсами навчальних
закладів фінанси відділ кадрів те що ми
знаємо в деякі продукти які широко
використовуються раніше зараз вони
знаходяться під санкціями
динамікс дозволяє
налаштувати повністю керування
моніторинг аналіз в освітній діяльності
кожного навчального закладу також Крім
того ми працюємо над долученням
партнерів та для постачання більше 120
тисяч девайсів в Україну найближчим
часом ми знаємо що вже частина була
надана з професійною системою Windows і
також найближчим часом будуть нові
постачання ця цифра буде обов'язково
рости
крім цього Ми займаємося таким тренінгом
напрямку це локалізація навчальних
ресурсів Microsoft Word Life Та
фундаментус щоб кожен освітянин в
Україні міг українською мовою вивчати
продукти Microsoft впроваджувати
їх у своєму академічному та поза
академічному життям також і тут ми
хотіли також додати що сертифікація
фундаментус та Microsoft Office фактично
ці ресурси які надаємо Microsoft є
міжнародною прийнятими вони
використовуються в усьому світі і
фундаментус портал дає також можливість
пройти певний курс Відповідно до ваших
вимог вашої специфіки роботи і по
закінченню курси Ви можете отримати
сертифікат який буде використовуватися в
усьому світі буде визнаватися у всьому
світі
акцентуючись на позашкільній освіті як
додатковій освіті ми працюємо з юнісеф в
напрямку впровадження головний пас це
все що стосується онлайн навчання для
дітей позашкільної програми
крім того для шкіл пропонуємо в
Minecraft який також локалізований на
українську мову середньої освіти і ми
вже власне почали проводити такі живі
уроки де дітки можуть побігати наприклад
по Києву так чи інші містам в Україні і
віртуальному світі Minecraft і
виконувати завдання які використовують
які їм дає викладач і власне потім
підвантажувати їх в систему для
оцінювання це
такий цікавий ресурси які ми
впроваджуємо в принципі плануємо впадити
в середню освіту ширше
Ми продовжуємо
програму Microsoft Expert для тих
вчителів Скажімо так які прагнуть
привнести якийсь новітні рішення в
учбовий процес і використовують
без ресурсів які ми надаємо Microsoft Ця
програма для таких освітян
хотів би через підкреслити що всі ці
можливості вони надаються безкоштовно
для освіти в Україні Microsoft зараз
лише приносить своє фінансування і
любий Світлани можуть отримати певний
ресурс Абсолютно безкоштовно крім того
для поширення Скажімо так підтримки
в Україні з цифрової трансформацією в
світі а також для
щоб зробити цю підтримку такої більш
довготривалої ми долучаємо
долучали і довіряємо
інший донорські організації і вони
розширюють ту підтримку яка надається
там через ресурси через ліцензію через
девайси Ми продовжуємо рухатися в цьому
напрямку далі
як отримати більше інформації про те що
пропонує Microsoft якщо ви середня
освіта то Міністерство освіти науки
надаватиме вам інформацію безпосередньо
через свої власні канали централізовано
стосується професійної освіти але тут ми
також працюємо ще з gz Present в Україні
тому що ми працюємо з пілотами школами
які надаємо також поширені такі більш
продвинуті ліцензії м365 Якщо ж вища
освіта то це знову ж таки через
Міністерство освіти науки а також Через
спілкою ректорів яка діє як організація
парасолька тоді вищої освіти в цілому з
будь-яких питань ви можете звертатися за
цією електронною адресою Це моя
електронна адреса Я радий підтримую вас
на вашому шляху цифровий трансформації і
забезпечують щоб Microsoft для вас
максимально легким та корисним
Дякую колеги
Дякуємо пане Олександре а Ми продовжуємо
нашу роботу і до слова Я запрошую пана
Івана юрічука прошу колеги Вітаю
якщо мене добре чути То я спробую
ввімкнути презентацію правильно
так
якщо це в мене вийде
друзі чи видно мою
презентацію
Це добре все добре Так дякую
Шановні колеги радий вітати вас від
великої дружньої команди державної
служби якості освіти коли кілька років
тому
ухвалювався закон про освіту А пізніше
закон про повну загальну середню освіту
Ми всі мріяли про нову якість освіти
але ми також розуміли що ці мрії
неможливі без сучасних рішень ми
розуміли що тільки поєднання такої
хорошої ідеї і тих цифрових рішень які
на сьогодні існують може дати нам
ті
можливості які би ми хотіли мати ті
можливості для кожної школи і ті
можливості для державної служби якості
освіти і для Міністерства освіти
Таким чином ми
почали роботу над цифровою системою
зовнішнього оцінювання та самооцінювання
освітньої управлінської діяльності
закладів освіти у цьому відразу потрібно
сказати що у цьому питанні ми
започаткували хорошу співпрацю з нашими
чеськими колегами значить з нашими
чеськими партнерами і ця співпраця
триває вже також кілька років
коли ми говоримо про систему
забезпечення якості Ми повинні знати
розуміти що в основі такої системи
лежать два базові елементи це
самооцінювання та зовнішнє оцінювання
процесів які відбуваються в закладі
освіти
інформаційно-аналітична система для
зовнішнього оцінювання та самооцінювання
освітніх і управлінських процесів у
закладах освіти для себе Ми таку систему
коротко назвали евальвет що ж це за
система і що вона може дати закладам
освіти і директорам як у правдінцям
отже
як і будь-яка система будь-яка
інформаційно-аналітична система
відкриває хороші можливості для
мінімізації суб'єктивного впливу на
результат оцінювання для відстеження
динаміки та вчасно реагування на
виявлені проблеми для накопичення та
аналізу даних що важливо для ухвалення
рішень які базуються на цих достовірних
даних а також диверсифікація джерел
отримання інформації дозволяє
аналізувати стан системи на різних
рівнях починаючи від закладу освіти на
рівні громади на рівні області і на
рівні країни
і такий важливий аспект - це прозорість
власне зовнішнього оцінювання та
самооцінювання
що ж це дасть що ж використання такої
системи дасть директору школи
як уже згадував пан Андрій попередній
спікер говорив про те що у їхній школі
вони створили своє власне рішення для
того щоб можна було використовувати
абетку для директора яка дає Яку
підготувала державна служба якості
освіти яка дає розуміння керівнику
закладу освіти як можна побудувати у
внутрішню систему забезпечення якості
освіти у себе в закладі
фактично система яку ми називаємо
еволюет це оцифровано абетка для
директора це
величезна величезний набір критеріїв за
якими заклад освіти може оцінити власну
освітню і управлінську діяльність і що
важливо оцінюючи таку оцінюючи свою
діяльність заклад освіти має може бути
переконаний що коли у закладі буде
відбуватися зовнішнє оцінювання воно
буде відбуватися за тими самими
критеріями і показниками Таким чином
забезпечується спільне розуміння якості
освіти а також заклад освіти отримує
можливість
чітко розуміти де які переваги є у цьому
конкретному закладі освіти а також
проблемні місця над якими треба
працювати директору школи директор
закладу освіти може бути переконаний що
зовнішній експерти які будуть оцінювати
у майбутньому заклад освіти будуть
працювати за тими самими критеріями
оце що ви бачите зараз на екрані це
Приклади того що зможе побачити керівник
закладу освіти використовуючи таку
систему для оцінювання освітніх і
управлінських процесів у своєму закладі
освіти і найважливіше ця система зараз
відбувається на етапі апробації і я
сподіваюся що на початку вересня близько
третини закладів освіти зможуть отримати
запрошення до такої апробації Спочатку
це буде звичайно простіший процес це
буде дистанційний збір даних ми плануємо
спокусуватися на вивченні організованого
початку навчального року але в
майбутньому я думаю що десь уже з жовтня
місяця ми зможемо почати розпочати
використання цієї системи для
самооцінювання українських освітніх
процесів у закладі освіти тому друзі
колеги директори закладів освіти
Очікуйте повідомлення і я вірю що ми
спільно з вами зможемо з використанням
такої
такой інформаційно-аналітичної системи
побудувати кращу якість освіти
розбудувати внутрішні системи
забезпечення якості освіти і забезпечити
добру якісну освіту для наших
українських дітей які
побудують нашу Прекрасну Україну
майбутнього друзі Всім дякую за увагу
якщо є питання готовий відповідати
дякую пані Іване і Ми продовжуємо нашу
роботу і у нас на часі заключне слово до
якого я якраз Я запрошую пані Роксолану
швача прошу
Вітаю колеги сподіваюсь сподіваюсь мене
чутно видно
сподіваюсь що наша панель з цифрової
трансформації вас не втомила але ще
надихнула і мотивувала на подальшу
роботу мені повідомляють що наша панель
завершує роботу одна з останніх тому я
дякую найстійкішим що були з нами весь
цей час та взаємодіяли
спікеру і заключним словом завжди важко
втримати аудиторію чимось новим бо вже
все важливе було сказано хтось втомився
а хтось найсумлінніший ще з 10-ї ранку
слухав міністра потім відвідав всі 20
локацій Ви молодці дякуємо вам за це я
постараюсь не затримувати а підведу
підсумки і подякую
Як ви побачили робота в напрямі цифрової
трансформації ведеться системно і на
всіх рівнях ті чотири блоки яким ми
сьогодні присвятили майже три години
робочого часу це є ключові цілі Як казав
на початку Дмитро Завгородній 4 кити на
яких тримається цифрова трансформація
освіти цифрова інфраструктура
електронний контент онлайн процеси і
послуги цифрові навички це ті блоки які
мають як мантру запам'ятати усі команди
освітян цифровізаторів на місцях Саме ці
цілі включені в проект стратегії
цифрової трансформації Освіти і Науки до
2025 року саме над цими цілями працює
наша цифрова команда міносвіти 24/7 і
саме над ними проситимемо вас працювати
в подальшому
знаю що нас чекають загалом нелегкі часи
по суті Ми вже в них живемо попри ту
біду яка насунулась на нас попри те що
ми маємо вчитися виживати буквально
Кожного дня ми ще й повинні не
відставати в сучасних технологіях
постійно професійно розвиватися
вдосконалюватися а освітяни в першу
чергу проте якраз завдяки нашим
інноваційним освітянам завдяки
діджиталізації Нам вдалося продовжити
освіту під час ковіду Нам вдалося не
зупинити її під час війни завдяки нашим
сміливим освітянам ми можемо бути
впевнені що освіта продовжуватиметься а
це означає що майбутнє у нас є і
перемога у нас буде
звичайно всі представлені результати І
навіть проведення цієї локації були б
неможливими без постійної підтримки
наших стратегічних партнерів Дякуємо
колегам із Міністерства цифрової
трансформації України
підпорядкованим установам і мінусвіти
особливо інституту освітньої аналітики
українському інституту розвитку освіти в
державному підприємству Інфоресурс а
також колегам з державної служби якості
освіти Академії підпад наук та інших
Дякуємо народним депутатам України
громадському сектору освіторія батьки
сос та іншим Корпорація Google і
Microsoft та іншим технологічним
компаніям які завжди на наш перший запит
готові підтримувати освіту звичайно Ми
дякуємо всім нашим міжнародним партнерам
Ну і академії цифрового розвитку та
особисто пані антоніні букач яка
сьогодні так в майстерно модерувала Нашу
З вами панель
Я сподіваюся що кожен Слухач Сьогодні
взяв для себе щось нове і корисне у разі
питань звертайтеся Наша команда
директорату цифрової трансформації
відкрита до будь-яких комунікацій Ми
потребуємо ваших ідей вашого досвіду та
зворотнього зв'язку
ми бажаємо вам почати цей новий
навчальний рік в натхненні заради дітей
і впевненості в перемозі віримо освітнім
і збройним силам України слава Україні
до нових зустрічей